So I'm going to briefly review some of
what I told you last time and then I'm
going to walk through,
as I mentioned,
I'm going to walk through the Disney
Film Pinocchio and which I presume most
of you have seen.
How many of you have seen it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well that's,
that's so as I think I mentioned,
that's something in and of itself,
right?
I mean the fact that you've all seen it
means that it's a production of cultural
significance and because it's such a
strange artifact,
that's one way of looking at it.
It might be worth trying to take it
apart to understand why it is,
for example,
that you even understand it.
And so I offered you the proposition
last week that we view the world
essentially through a narrative lens and
I believe that we view the world through
a narrative lens because the fundamental
problem that we have to solve as living
creatures is how we should act in the
world.
And that means how we should act to
maintain ourselves,
but also how we need to act in
relationship to other people and in
relationship to the broader world.
In order to maintain ourselves across
time,
so that's a complicated problem,
right?
It's not just how you survive,
it's how you survive now and next week
and next month and next year and 50
years from now and maybe your,
your,
uh,
your descendants as well if the culture
is going to stabilize and then not only
you across all those timeframes,
but you and everyone else across all
those timeframes so viciously difficult
problems.
And so I would say that we have evolved
mechanisms to solve that.
I think that's self evident in some
sense because for example,
one of the mechanisms that animals have
evolved to deal with the problem of
social being,
even if they're not particularly social
animals,
is the dominance hierarchy.
Right?
Or You could call it a hierarchy of
authority or power because I think
considering human structures,
social structures as mirror power
structures is a terrible mistake.
It's a terrible oversimplification
because power is by no means the only
like force is what I mean.
Force is not a stable way of solving the
problem of how to live together across
time.
The question is what is the stable way
of solving how to live together across
time and that really is the question and
it's part of the question that I'm
trying to answer,
partly because it's a perennial problem,
right?
We,
we face the problem of how to organize
ourselves in small social units without
undue conflict and then we faced the
larger problem of how to organize
ourselves into large social units
without
undue conflict and that conflict can be
absolutely devastating and,
and,
and frequently is so.
So then I would also say that the first
way of solving this problem isn't
conscious.
You see not at all.
And you know,
you may know and you may not know that
there are,
there are different forms of memory,
right?
Really technically different forms of
memory.
So for example,
there's short term working memory,
which is the memory that you use to hold
things like telephone numbers in your
active imagination.
It decays very rapidly.
It's only about four to seven bits,
which is why well,
it's white phone numbers or were at
least seven digits long.
You know,
you can kind of manage that as a loop.
That and then there's um,
episodic memory and that has two
elements.
One is semantic and the other is a
episodic.
It's a,
what's the name of that?
Someone's.
Someone said something.
Yes.
Well there's procedural memory and then
there's,
there's another the kind of memory that
you use to represent your experiences to
yourself.
So let's say it's image Laden and the
other one is semantic and semantic is
your memory for facts and those are
quite different.
So for example,
procedural memory,
that's how you ride a bike,
that's how you play the piano,
that's how you play jazz music.
If you're in a combo,
it's,
it's the memory,
it's in fact,
it's a funny kind of memory because it's
actually built right into you,
you know,
I mean so is so is the kind of memory
that you use to represent your life,
but it's much more malleable in some
sense.
So what that means is that in your
procedures there is information that you
don't know about at patterned
information that you don't know about.
Part of that is how to act,
you know,
like when you walk into a social
gathering,
you don't really think through how
you're going to act,
you know,
how to act and if someone asked you
exactly what it is that you're doing and
why you could formulate a story about
it,
but the probability that,
that it's the existence of that story
that enabled you to act that way as zero
because you have to react way faster
than that.
And so you know,
you have social knowledge built into
your nervous system because you've
practiced being a social being for a
very long period of time.
And of course then that social being has
been shaped for forever really.
And it's the right way of thinking about
it.
You know,
we know that animals organize themselves
into hierarchies and we'll say of
dominance because it's more,
more true the farther back you go in
time,
at least since the time of the
crustaceans.
You know,
when we split from our common ancestor
300 million years ago.
And so it's true for social animals and
non social animals.
So even animals that don't live together
in groups have to organize themselves
into a hierarchy in this space.
They inhabit songbirds are a good
example and they have dominance disputes
all the time.
Partly that's you can hear them having
their little dominance disputes in the
spring when they're singing because
basically what they're saying is I'm
pretty damn healthy and I'm ready to go
and if you're another bird like me,
you better steer clear of this tree.
And,
and the,
the dominant songbirds,
no,
they don't live together crozer social,
but most songbirds aren't.
The dominant songbirds get the best nest
and the best nest is the one that
doesn't get rained on and isn't,
it's not too windy and it's close to
food sources and you know,
and so then they have the healthiest
chicks and they attract the best mates
and like it's really important where
you're positioned in the hierarchy,
even if you're not like a flock or herd
creature.
Now we're more like herd creatures.
So it's even more,
it's even,
it's even more relevant to us,
but there's just no escaping a
hierarchical arrangement in,
in,
in social being.
That is social being and,
and,
and it's evolutionarily ancient beyond
conception.
So 300 million years ago there weren't
trees,
you know,
I mean,
so the dominance hierarchies older than
trees.
So that's really something to think
about.
And then you know,
when you're thinking about the reality
that shaped us say from an evolutionary
perspective,
but also from a cultural perspective,
what you have to understand is that the
things that have shaped us most are the
things that have been around the longest
and so you could say those are the most
real things and you can't even see some
of them.
Like,
it's not like you can come in here.
Well it's not exactly true.
You can't come in here and see the
multiple dominance hierarchies that are
at work.
You can't in a way because the chairs
are set up to face this way and I'm
facing that way.
That gives you some clues about the
social order here and you take the cues
instantly,
right?
You come down,
you sit in the chairs,
you organize yourselves according to
mutual expectation,
and that's part of your procedural
knowledge about how to behave as a
social creature.
Now that knowledge is really,
really deep and a lot of it's coded in
your behavior now and another people's
behavior as well and that's you know,
that's,
that's the expectations you have of
other people,
end of yourself and a lot of those are
implicit,
right?
So when we're interacting,
there's,
there's a,
there's a very large number of things
that you just don't get to do and you
know that too and you won't do them.
And that way we can act as if we
understand each other even though we
don't because you're really complicated
and I'm really complicated and there's
lots of situations where we might really
be in conflict,
but because we share a map of the
culture,
the cultural expectations,
it makes part of our.
It's built right into our perception.
You will act out that set of
expectations and so will I,
and if neither of us can do that,
even if one of us can't,
we're going to stay.
We're either going to immediately
devolve into conflict or we're going to
avoid each other like the plague,
and that's exactly the right thing to
do,
and so one of the really useful things
to understand in this took me a long
time to formulate properly.
You know,
you hear the terror management theorists
for example,
and they have this idea that you're.
You're meaning representation.
The story you tell about the world
regulates your,
your death,
anxiety.
It's something like that,
but that's not right.
I mean it's close to right and it's a
smart idea.
It came from Ernest Becker,
by the way,
who wrote a book called the denial of
death,
which is actually quite a good book even
though it's wrong,
you know,
sometimes a book can be very useful.
It can be usefully wrong in that,
and Becker's book is usefully wrong
because he thought that it's the
internal representation of your belief
system that regulates your anxiety and
that anxiety is fundamentally in the
final analysis anxiety about death.
It's like,
well,
okay,
fine.
It's a reasonable proposition,
but that isn't how it works.
You see,
it isn't my beliefs right now that are
regulating my emotions.
It's the fact that I'm acting out those
beliefs which include implicit
perceptions.
I'm acting them out and so are you,
and so what you're doing and what I
expect more,
more accurately,
what you're doing and what I want you to
do and the way I want you to react to me
that's working,
so it's the match between my belief
system and the way everyone else is
acting that's regulating my emotions.
It's not the belief system.
It's mediated by the social culture and
you see if you understand this,
then you understand more particularly
why people are willing to fight to the
bitter end to protect their culture.
It's not a psychological structure that
they're protecting.
It's a psychological structure and a
sociological structures,
symbol tanium.
So the social contract is you have a set
of expectations and I have a set of
expectations there actually desires.
They're not merely expectations because
as living creatures,
we're desirous,
we don't just expect and so you desired
outcome and I desired outcome and we
agree to act in accordance with that.
That's the social contract,
and so people don't like having that
disrupted.
Well,
it isn't because it's psychologically
destabilizes them.
Although it does.
It's because it actually destabilizes
stuff,
right?
If all of a sudden we can't occupy the
same specified domain of territory,
it isn't only that we're thrown into
psychological disarray,
although we will be.
It's that will start fighting with each
other like,
and that can kill you.
It's no joke.
It kills people a lot.
Like it happens.
It can happen very easily,
that are cohesive.
Social Group can fragment along some
fracture line of identity,
let's say.
And all hell breaks loose.
You know,
that's what happened with the Tutsis and
the Hutus and in,
uh,
in Rwanda,
you know,
and those things can get out of control
just so fast.
It's just unbelievable.
And so,
and that wasn't death anxiety,
that was death.
That's a whole different thing.
And that's the other thing that Tara
management people don't exactly get.
It's like,
it isn't just that your culture and your
cultural beliefs protect you from
anxiety and say anxiety about death.
Even it's that they actually protect you
from death as well as protecting you
from death,
anxiety.
I mean,
look,
it's warm in here.
It's cold outside.
The fact that the culture is intact
means that you're not outside freezing.
That's a hell of a lot more fundamental
in some sense than mere anxiety.
Although I'm not trying to underplay the
role of anxiety.
That's a major issue,
but there's something that's a lot more
fundamental at stake than mere
psychology,
so it's the match between your map of
the world and other people's actions
that regulates your emotion and it
regulates it completely because you know
if,
if someone in here started acting
seriously,
deranged,
like brandish a pistol,
let's say all of a sudden you would not
be in the same place at all,
not a bit,
and so what would happen?
Well,
chaos would happen and chaos isn't just
that you would get anxious.
That's not a good enough explanation.
What would happen is more complex than
not.
What happens in some senses that your
body and it does this,
does this.
What would happen is that you would
react the same way that it reacts to a
cat.
It's exactly that.
You would respond as if a terrible
Predator had emerged in your midst.
And so what is that reaction?
Well,
it's not just anxiety because when you
encounter a Predator,
anxiety isn't the only thing that's
useful that just makes you freeze.
It's like that could be the worst thing
you could do.
You freeze and while you're a pretty
easy target.
So you have to be prepared for a lot
broader range of responses.
The Mirror Mirror Mirror,
petro,
fication,
like how about a little aggression that
might be helpful.
You don't know.
It also might get you killed,
but you know,
maybe you can take the guy down and
maybe that's a good idea.
You know,
and,
and maybe you have to run.
So that's disinhibited as well and maybe
you have to think really quickly and
reflexively.
So that happens.
That's activated,
disinhibited I would say as well.
It's like your whole being is thrown
into intense concentration on the moment
and you're burning up physiological
resources like mad.
And so what will happen after something
like that,
if you don't develop outright
posttraumatic stress disorder,
which some of you would,
is that you assuming that the situation
was brought under control,
you'd walk out of here shaking with your
heart rate at one 70 and it would take
you like while it might take you the
rest of your life,
and maybe you would never recover,
but you can bloody well be sure that it
would take you the rest of the day.
That's for sure.
And so it's no joke when someone steps
steps outside the confines of the social
contract,
right?
And that's Kinda.
There's a philosopher named hobbs who I
suppose in some sense was essentially
conservative philosopher as opposed to
Russo,
who's kind of his exact opposite.
Rousseau believed that people were
basically good in their natural state.
So he believed nature was basically good
and he believed that culture was
corrupted people.
And so and uh,
uh,
Hobbs,
Thomas hobbes believed exactly the
opposite.
He believed that in the state of nature,
let's say every person was at every
other person's throat.
And the only thing that prevented
continual chaos was the imposition of a,
of a collective agreement that would be
the social contract that essentially
governed how people would interact and
that would keep that underlying chaos at
bay.
And you know,
my contention is is that hobbes was
correct and Russolo was correct.
And,
and,
and I think that if you add Russo and
hobbs together,
you get a total picture of the world.
And that's really,
I think the picture of the world that
I'm trying to relate to you.
It's both at once.
It's like,
well you can't just attribute human
malevolence and unpredictability to
society.
It's just,
it's a nonstarter.
It's like people build society.
So all you're doing is pushing the
problem back.
It's like where did it come from?
Well,
society,
the society before.
Well then the one before that,
it's like,
well you got to tangle up the individual
in there at some point because people
created society.
And so you can't just blame human
irrationality and malevolence on
society.
Well,
and also it's,
it's ungrateful for God's sake.
It's like society obviously also makes
you peaceful.
Part of the reason you're a peaceful
right now all of you is because while
you're not that hungry,
you're certainly not starving to death.
You would be a very,
very different person if you were
starving right now,
you know,
or if you were enraged or if you were
panicking or if you were terrified
because your.
Your future was radically uncertain.
I mean,
you're just not any of those people
right now.
You're satiated that I mean that
technically you're satisfied.
None of your biological systems except
perhaps curiosity,
which is a rather pleasant emotion are
activated in the least and you know,
because of that,
you all think,
well,
you're in control of yourself,
but don't be thinking that that's just
not right.
I mean,
if you look at how the brain is
structured,
for example,
the Hypothalamus,
which is a really important part of the
brain,
it basically,
it basically establishes the framework
of reference and the actions,
the framework of reference within which
and the actions you take in order to
fulfill basic biological needs.
So the hypothalamus makes you thirsty
and the hypothalamus makes you hungry
and it makes you sexually aroused.
If it puts you into a state of defensive
aggression and it,
it actually also makes you explore and
be curious.
All of that,
hypothalamic,
it's an amazing structure.
And then,
and it's really small and it's right at
the base of the brain.
Um,
and you could imagine it as something
that has tremendously powerful
projections upward throughout the rest
of the brain,
into the emotional systems in the
cortical systems and all of that,
like tree trunk size connections,
you know,
metaphorically speaking.
And then the cortex has these little
like vine,
like tendrils going down to regulate the
hypothalamus,
you know,
and if it's,
when push comes to shove man,
the hypothalamus that thing winds.
And so,
you know,
you get people now and then who have a
hypothalamic dysfunction and one of them
produces a condition called,
I can't remember it.
It's not dip.
So mania,
although it's,
it's like that doesn't matter.
It produces uncontrollable thirst.
And so what will happen is that people
who have this hypothalamic problem will
drown themselves by drinking water,
which,
which you can do by the way.
Uh,
and so they just cannot get enough water
and there's no stopping them,
right?
No,
no more than there would be stopping you
if you were suffering from raging
thirst.
It's like,
it's a happy day when the hypothalamus
is not telling you what to do and you
know,
you live in such a civilized state that
most of the time,
roughly speaking,
you're tranquil and satisfied and more
or less you can imagine yourself as a
peaceful,
you know,
productive well meaning entity,
but don't be thinking that that's what
you'd be if you were put in the right
situation because that's just not right
at all.
So,
you know,
lots of times soldiers develop
posttraumatic stress disorder because
they go out to the battlefield,
they're kind of naive.
They're young guys,
you know,
and,
uh,
it actually is worse if they're not that
bright.
It turns out because having a lower Iq
is one of the things that predisposes
you to post traumatic stress disorder.
But anyways,
they go out in the battlefield and they
see what they're capable of under
battlefield conditions.
And like,
you know,
we,
we had been fighting wars for a very
long time,
millions of years,
you know,
chimps basically have wars with other
chimps,
the troops,
right?
Because the juveniles will patrol the
perimeter,
the perimeter of their territory and if
they find other chimps from other troops
that they outnumber,
they will tear them to pieces like in
chimps are really,
really strong.
And so when I say they'll tear them to
pieces,
I mean that literally,
you know,
they,
they tear them to pieces.
And Jane Goodall discovered that
originally in the 19 seventies,
she didn't even report it for awhile
because she was so shocked,
you know,
she kind of assumed like most followers
of ruth soul,
that the human proclivity for warfare
was part.
That part.
That was something that was a uniquely
human.
You know,
it had something to do with our,
our unique self consciousness or
intelligence or something like that.
She had no idea that it was rooted that
deeply,
you know,
we,
we split from chimps about six,
7 million years ago,
something like that.
And so we were patrolling territory.
We were gang members 7 million years ago
and you know at that that's minimum
estimation because of course that
ancestor shaded back maybe 20 million
years into entities that were roughly
primate like and so territoriality and a
and a proclivity to defend territory is
so deeply embedded in us.
It's,
it's,
it's like,
it's like it's the control center for
our whole brain and so there isn't
anything more important to us,
I would say.
Then maintaining the match between what
we want to have happen and what other
people are doing in response to our
actions.
Like that's that that's what we want and
as long as that match is maintained,
then our emotional systems and I would
say anxiety's probably primary in that
regard.
Our emotional systems remain inhibited.
They're on,
they're ready,
like,
like a nuclear reactor.
Rods are on and the rest of the brain
dampens them down.
But it's like if you don't want them to
take time to start up,
man,
you want them to be on at a,
at a 10th of a second's notice when it's
necessary.
And so,
you know,
that's kind of why.
Well,
if you look like look at a wild animal,
it's like it's alert,
you know it's ready to dark this way or
that way,
especially a prey animal instantaneously
and it has reflex is built into it as
you do that will respond way before your
conscious.
So for example,
if you happen to be walking down a trail
and you detect something snake like in
the periphery,
you'll leap away before you even know
that you lapped and,
but that's because it takes a fair bit
of time to actually see a snake by which
I mean form a conscious representation
of the snake,
you know,
and maybe it takes a quarter of a second
or something like that,
or even longer,
but it doesn't matter.
Maybe it takes 10.
No 20th of a set a 10th of a second.
But the thing about the damn snake is
it's way faster than that.
It's really fast.
That thing,
and it evolved with primates by the way.
And so it can nail you like way faster
than you can look at it.
So you have your eyes map,
snake like objects,
right onto your reflexes so that the
eyes go to eyes make you jump,
and then they see after that,
it's like,
yeah,
well now you can see that's no problem,
you know,
so.
Alright,
alright,
now what I would say that what we do is
we live in a shared story and the story
is a way of looking at the world and its
way of acting in the world at the same
time.
And that story has to operate within
narrow parameters.
And this is something that's
extraordinarily important to understand
because,
and this is something I think that
piaget figured out,
John Piaget figured out better than
anyone else.
I think he really got this right.
And by the way,
one of the things that piaget was trying
to do,
you never hear about how strange these
great thinkers are.
But Piaget was a very strange guy and he
was a,
he was a hyper genius.
He was offered the curatorship of a
bloody museum when he was 10 years old,
you know,
because he wrote this little paper on
mollusks,
which parent was a very good and so they
offered him the curatorship of a museum
and his parents wrote back and said,
well,
you know,
no,
probably not because he's,
he's actually ted.
And so that was piaget man,
the guy who was a genius and you know,
he,
he was actually motivated by the desire
to reconcile science and religion.
That was,
that was actually his entire motivation
for what he did.
You never hear that,
but that's the case.
And so piaget was very interested in how
you produce structures that enable you
to regulate yourself because you're like
a kind of a,
a colony of strange sub animals that
have to figure out how to get along so
that you can sort of be one thing.
You kind of learned that I would say
between the ages of two and four as
you're being socialized,
you know how erratic two year olds are.
I mean,
they're a blast and it's part because
they were erratic.
It's like they're unbelievably happy and
then they're unbelievably hungry and
then they're really hot and then they're
really upset and crying,
you know,
and then they're really scared.
It's like,
and all of that just untrammeled.
And so it's really fun to be around
them,
especially when they're happy because
they're so happy that it's just,
you know,
you don't ever get to be that happy and
so it's nice to be around the two year
old because you can kinda feel that
again,
you know,
in a lot of what the.
One of the horrible things about being a
parent is that you spend a tremendous
amount of your time making your child
less happy.
And the reason for that is that positive
emotion is a very impulsive,
you know,
and you know because everybody says,
well,
you should be happy.
It's like,
well no,
when you're happy you're actually quite
stupid.
And so because happiness makes you
impulsive,
happiness makes happiness says,
hey,
things are really good right now.
Get what you can while the getting's
good.
And so as a,
like,
if you're hyper optimistic,
manic will say it's like every stock
investment looks like a really good
stock investment.
It's like you won't spend all your money
because look at those wonderful things
everywhere and you could do such great
things with them and then,
you know,
you spend all your money and then you
crash and you think,
Oh God,
my life's over,
you know,
because I just,
I just spent all my money on all this
useless stuff.
And it's all under the grip of
impulsive,
positive emotion,
you know?
And so when,
when you're telling your kids to be
quiet and settled down,
it isn't because they're making a lot of
noise.
Being in pain is because they're running
around like wild baboons having a blast
and disrupting things like mad,
you know,
and you got kids,
you got to settle down,
you know,
like quit having so much fun and it's,
it's kind of awful that you do that,
but what you do.
And that's because the emotions and the
motivations have to be brought into a
relationship with one another within the
person.
So that,
you know,
one thing I remember with my son who is
quite,
he's quite disagreeable by temperament,
which is actually a good thing as far as
I'm concerned,
although it brings its own challenges.
And so with my daughter when she was
misbehaving,
she was pretty agreeable and uh,
you know,
if she was misbehaving I could basically
just look at her and then she'd quit,
you know,
but my son was like,
that was just nothing.
You're looking at me.
It's like,
no,
that's not gonna go anywhere man.
And so then I'd tell him to stop and
that really wasn't having much of an
effect either.
He just sort of maybe laugh or runaway
or whatever.
I mean,
he was a tough little rat and you know,
what I would do with him is he would be
doing something and it interfered and
he'd get upset and you know,
angry.
And so then I get them to sit on the
steps and I told him when he was about
to,
I said,
look,
you're going to sit on the steps.
That's time out.
You're going to sit on the steps until
you've got control of yourself and you
can come back and be and play the family
game again.
I basically said,
be a civilized human being and then
you're welcome again,
and so he'd sit on the steps.
It was so interesting to watch because
he was just enraged.
He'd sit there like,
have you ever seen a two year old have a
temper tantrum?
It's really quite the bloody phenomena.
If you ever saw an adult do that,
you'd like,
you'd call nine one one right away.
And it's like,
Oh my God,
I've seen adults do that.
You know,
because people say with borderline
personality disorder will have temper
tantrums,
and it's like,
man,
you want to be about 30 feet away from
that person.
That's for sure.
It's really.
But in kids it's like,
well first of all,
they're only this long,
so how much trouble can they really
cause?
But it's like,
you know,
they're just completely gone there.
Like on the floor of their face is red.
They're just furious,
like way more furious than you ever get.
If you are even vaguely socialized
there.
Just outraged and they're kicking and
hitting the ground and like,
it's like a little epileptic fits of
anger,
you know,
they're completely controlled by their
rage and we took care of one kid for
awhile who he was actually a pushover,
that kid you could get them to behave
by,
you know,
kind of shaking your finger at him.
But his mother thought he was really
tough because he had her,
he had her figured out and one of the
things he would do is have a temperature
temper tantrum and during the temper
tantrum he would hold his bloody breath
until he turned blue.
It's like,
try that,
like you know,
as that's your homework.
Go home and go home and have a temper
tantrum and while you're doing it,
hold your breath until you actually turn
blue.
It's like you won't be able to do it.
You don't have the willpower of a two
year old,
that's for sure.
That little varmint man,
he just had a fit.
Then he'd hold his breath and then he
turned blue.
It was like,
wow,
that's,
that's amazing.
And we would just like,
let them do it.
You know.
He turned blue and everybody would be
gone and he'd come out of it,
you know,
and it didn't work.
So he just quit doing it.
I think he did it like twice and he
figured out,
oh well that's a lot of work for very
little outcome and you know,
it's not like two year olds are stupid.
They're,
they're not stupid.
They're probably smarter than you,
but they're not civilized by any stretch
of the imagination.
And so anyways,
back to my son,
I'd put them on the steps and he'd be
like,
oh,
it's just like aged and trying to get
himself together,
you know?
And I wait a few,
few,
I got a strict rule which was as soon as
you're done,
you're welcome again.
So it's completely under your control.
You,
you get yourself calmed down,
you come and talk to me again.
If you're calm enough,
so I like you,
then you're welcome back in the family.
No grudge or nothing.
And so it's harder than you think.
Like people think they liked their kids.
It's like,
don't be thinking that they're hard to
like they're little monsters and they're
very,
very pushy.
And provocative and so lots of parents
do not like their children and they do
terrible things to them their whole
life.
So it's no joke and it's a very common
and you know,
that was Freud's observation,
fundamental observation that a lot of
psychopathology is rooted in the family
and you can be sure of that,
you know,
and when you hear about some mother
who's done something terrible to her
child,
which happens reasonably frequently,
you know perfectly well that she has a
very terrible capacity to discipline.
The child is just provoked her and
provoked or unprovoked or and provoked
or unprovoked or.
And it just happens to be a day where
her new boyfriend left and she's quite
hung over and she got fired and it's
like that was the wrong data provoker.
And then she does something that is not
good and you read about it and you
think,
well,
how could that happen?
How could anyone do that?
Well,
that's how they do it.
And so,
and kids are very provocative,
just like little chimps.
Chimps will.
The adolescents will like throw little
pebbles and sticks at the sleeping
larger males and bug them and that
teasing,
which it is,
that teasing turns into full fledged
dominance,
challenged behavior.
Once the adolescent males get big enough
to do it.
And so when you're being provoked by a
child,
which they provoke your time,
you're trying to figure out,
well,
just where are you exactly?
What happens if I do this?
What happens if I do this,
you know,
and how else are they going to figure it
out?
Anyways,
he'd sit on the steps and just,
he's just enraged and trying to control
himself.
And I'd watched that and then,
you know,
I come back after about two minutes or
whatever and he'd still be around.
I'd say,
well are,
you know,
have you got yourself under control?
Are you ready to get it off the steps?
And then,
you know,
he'd get himself under control and then
he'd come back and you know,
he'd be contrite and then I would like
them right away.
You know,
you go to watch that,
you know,
because you don't like being dominated
by a two year old.
No one does,
and so if the child hasn't mastered
himself and started to act in accordance
with the prevailing social norms,
you won't like them while you think,
oh yeah,
I will because you know I'm a good
person.
It's like,
no,
you won't,
and no,
you're not a good person,
so don't be thinking about that at all.
It's just not true.
So when he was contrite,
then he'd come and then we just go on
like nothing had happened because that's
what you want to do,
right?
As soon as you get compliance,
especially if the compliance is in the
best interest of the child,
you want to reward it instantly,
right?
That's the right thing to do because.
So then and,
and you could just see him gaining
control over himself.
And so really what was happening is his,
in his mind,
in his brain will say there was a war
between the psyche,
the ego that was starting to become
integrated and starting to become a
continuous person,
an identity,
and it's fragile in two year olds and it
can be disrupted all the time and it is.
That's why they're so hyper emotional.
It's fragile,
that little eagle and it doesn't have a
lot of power and so what you want to do
is reward it when it wins,
when it,
when he gets control over the underlying
motivations,
you want to say,
hey,
good work man,
good work kid.
You did it.
You know,
you guard yourself under control way to
be.
And the kids really happy about that
because it's actually not that much fun
to have a temper tantrum.
It's exhausting.
You know,
it takes you over question.
Oh,
just pat on the head or you know,
that's good.
That's a kind word,
you know,
or,
or whatever earth.
Yeah.
Notice it,
pay attention.
That's it.
Pay attention and that's a great.
It's a great thing to know with people
like in your relationships here.
Here's the key to a good relationship.
It's not the only one,
but watch your person carefully,
carefully,
and whenever they do something that you
would like them to do more of,
tell them that that was really good and
mean it.
And it's not manipulative because if
it's manipulated it won't work.
It's like you have to say,
wow,
I'm so glad you did that.
Did you have to be precise?
Here's what you just did that I thought
was great and Oh boy,
that's so nice that you've noticed.
I can't believe they can notice.
It's like,
you know,
you do that 20 times and the person will
be like the rat.
That's just pushing the lever for
cocaine.
You know,
so,
but no,
I'm serious.
It's a skinner established this bf
skinner noticed this a long time ago.
Reward is intensely useful in terms of
modifying behavior,
but the problem is is that it's really
hard to notice when things are going
right,
right?
Because of your kind of primed to notice
when things are going wrong and so you
use threat and punishment more often as
agents of,
of shaping the people that you're around
because you know when everything's going
right,
it's like,
what are you going to say?
Everything's going right.
It turns to zero.
You just assume it and that's,
that's not good.
That's not good.
You want to pay attention and if the
person,
your children,
your wife,
your whoever,
your mother,
your sister,
if you want them to,
if you want to rectify your
relationships with them,
and I'm not saying to do this in a
manipulative way,
won't work,
but if they do something that's
promoting harmony and peace and
goodwill,
it's like attend to it.
Tell them that you noticed.
It's like it's so useful and you have to
get rid of your grudges and your
resentment to do that,
right?
Because you don't want you to kind of
mad at your sister and then you know she
does something good.
You think there is no god damn way,
I'm going to reward you for that.
So you ignore her.
When she does something good.
It's like,
that's brilliant.
That is because then you've just
punished her for doing what you want,
and people do that with their kids all
the time,
you know,
because they let the kids dominate them.
Then they get resentful.
Then the kid will run up to them to show
them something that's kind of
spectacular and they'll they're not
happy.
They'll like,
oh yeah,
that's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm working,
you know,
little kid has all sad about that and
he's just learned something so,
and it's not perhaps what you want them
to learn.
And so you have to keep your,
your relationship with your children
pristine.
And that means that you can't hold a
grudge or resent them and that means
that you have to help them learn how to
behave so that you liked them and that
way if they,
if you like them and you're kind of
sensible and maybe your partner also
likes them.
So you know,
you got to consensus going there,
there's a reasonable possibility that
other people will actually like them to
including other children.
And then the world will open up to them,
you know,
then you'll bring them to people's
houses and the people will actually
smile at them and given them a pat on
the head and instead of thinking,
oh my God,
that brands coming to visit again,
I wonder what he'll break this time.
You know?
And that's just a horrible thing for
your child to experience repetitively in
situation after situation.
All they learned is that adults have a
false smile,
but they're really lying all the time.
God,
it's like a bit of hell and there's a
lot of children who are trapped in that.
It's really awful to see.
I can see kids like that when I walked
down the street,
you know,
it's like their little doomed things and
there they are and you know,
they're screwed in 15 different ways and
there's no way out of it.
It's really awful.
So I would not recommend that you do
that.
It's better to notice that you're a bit
of a monster or a lot of a monster and
notice that you are much happier with
the people around you when they behave
in accordance with reasonable source
social norms and then you actually feel
genuinely connected to them and you want
to work their behalf so that everything
works out.
But if you think you're a good person
and that you'd never do anything that
was harmful to your children,
then you can just forget about that
because you'll never take it seriously
enough to actually learn.
So.
Alright.
So anyways,
we live inside this story as far as I
can tell and you know,
we kind of put the story together inside
us to begin with and that happens
between two and four when you're
integrating those motivations and
emotions into a relatively functional
unity,
right?
And,
and,
and that does happen between two and
four.
If you don't have your kids socialized
by the time,
therefore you might as well just forget
it.
And I know that sounds terribly
pessimistic and all of that,
but I know the literature on trying to
rectify antisocial behavior in children
and after the age of four,
it's virtually impossible no matter what
you do.
And the reason for that is that kids who
are still acting like two year olds when
they're for that,
you know,
they're twice as old as a two year old.
That's a lot of difference.
Like a four year olds in adult as far as
a two year old is concerned.
And so if the four year old is still
acting like a two year old,
that's really not good.
And other four year olds will come up
and you know,
do a little play invitation like a dog
the,
the kid a two year old,
four year old has no idea how to react
to that.
And so the more mature kid thinks,
oh,
well how about a play with you?
And then that kid is isolated from the
peers and after four year mostly
socialized by your peers.
And so you just fall farther and farther
and farther behind.
You're more and more alienated.
You're more bitter and angry and no
wonder and it's just not.
You can't rectify it.
So,
so,
so that's useful to know.
It's like your job from two to four is
to turn your child,
help turn your child into a functional
unity and buy three.
They should be functional enough as a
unity within themselves so that they can
concentrate on a voluntary goal for some
reasonable length of time.
Which is also why it's useful to let
them spend some time alone so that they
can learn to amuse themselves.
Because if they can either be used
themselves,
they're not going to be able to play
with other kids and then by three
they're sorted together enough.
So if another three year old comes along
they can at least play in parallel and
may also start,
may be able to start playing a
cooperative game.
And so that's often a fantasy game,
you know,
pretend.
And so what the kids will do it,
sometimes they mediated verbally,
but sometimes it's more acted out.
It's a combination of the two.
They'll assign each other rules,
they'll do this with you too.
It's like,
let's have a tea party.
Well what does that mean?
Well,
it means let's sit down and act out the
act of sharing food and see if we can
get that right.
That's what the is saying.
I have a little tea party,
you know,
it's very important because he wouldn't
being shared food like this is a major
thing to get right man.
And so the kid will say,
well you be the mom and the dad and you
know,
we'll make little fort and that'll be
our house.
And we'll go in there and we'll run our
roles and you know,
we're acting out or acting out family
and,
and if,
if were both reasonably civilized as
three year olds,
we can concentrate on that goal.
We can establish that little fictional
world.
We can,
we can negotiate a mutual goal and then
we can run the simulation.
And that's what kids are doing when
they're pretending it's bloody
brilliant.
That's play man.
It's like,
it's brilliant.
It's absolutely unbelievable because you
know,
if you're going to play a mom,
let's say it isn't like you,
you,
it isn't exactly like you imitate your
mom because invitation would be,
you know how annoying it is when someone
copies you so you know you're sitting
like that.
And then I do the same thing.
It's like,
that's really annoying.
And if that isn't what kids do,
they don't act out the precise actions
that they've seen,
the target of their fantasy display.
There are way more sophisticated than
that.
They watch their mother,
let's say like hawks and then they start
to extract out regularities in their
behavior,
which is mum behavior.
Let's say that's what makes you mom
whatever that is and then so it's like
they,
they look at you across time and they
extract out the regularity that makes
you mother and then they try to embody
that regularity in there,
pretend play,
and then they sort of encapsulate or
incorporate the spirit of being a mother
or being a father or whatever,
or an animal because they'll play it
that.
And so that's what they're doing.
They're using their body and their mind
is dramatic forums.
It's really amazing.
You know,
it's so sophisticated and no other
animal does that as far as we know.
And it's the platform on which language
is based,
you know,
first of all we imitate and languages
imitation,
right?
Because we use the same words,
So it's imitation,
it's a big deal.
So you can act out someone else and then
you can conceptualize them in fantasy
and it's only way after that that you
could maybe articulate it like what does
it mean to be a mother?
So I could have you write an essay about
that.
Well,
you'd have to think about it,
right?
You wouldn't just automatically know,
but if someone hands you a baby and you
know you're not completely socially
blind,
you're roughly know what to do after
you're done with your initial
nervousness,
you roughly know what to do.
Don't drop it.
That's a good rule.
You've probably figured that one out.
At least you know,
don't yell at it,
don't startle it.
Give it a little pack,
maybe try hugging it.
Maybe you go like this,
you know,
we make eyes out it,
you know what to do.
It's built into you.
You know it's built into you,
but that doesn't mean you could lay it
out as a series of rules about how to be
a mother.
It's like you could write a whole damn
book about that.
So,
all right,
so anyways,
you live in this story and first of all,
you get your own story together and
that's by integrating your motivations
and emotions together under social
influence.
You know,
Piaget states that before the age of
three kids can't really play.
They're egocentric and it's not exactly
right because you're actually playing
with your mother from the time you're
born.
So even with breastfeeding that that's a
social interaction and it's a complex
cooperative endeavor and it's often hard
for mother and infant to get that right
because it's complicated and it requires
a lot of social interaction,
like while the child has to learn not to
bite,
for example,
you know,
and the mother has to learn not to be
too nervous and there's a lot of social
bonding.
It's really complicated social
interaction.
So the child,
the infant even at the earliest stages
is already engaged in a complex social
dynamic that's essentially play
oriented,
but it's,
you know,
it's pretty primordial.
It has to do mostly with the mouth and
child's mouth and tongue are already
hard wired at birth.
So your child is most Mrs.
Friday and observation as well.
Your child is almost all mouth and
tongue when it's born and the rest of
it's body.
While you watch infants,
like even when they're,
how old?
Seven months,
six months,
four months.
I can't even remember now.
You know,
they'll move their arm and they kind of
go like this.
It's like they have got no fine control
there.
It's more like they have,
you know,
clubs on the ends of sticks.
It's like that.
Their nervous system isn't thoroughly
myelinated.
They don't have control over themselves,
but their mouth and tongue are already
wired up and so otherwise they wouldn't
be able to swallow or or nurse.
So the oral element is extraordinarily
important for a young child.
That's why kids put everything in their
mouth,
you know,
even when they're a bit older,
it's like they're.
They see with their tongue,
which of course everyone can do.
You know,
if you put a block in your mouth,
you can tell that it's a like a cube.
You can tell that it's a cube without
looking at.
So you can see with your tongue and see
with your hands can even see to some
degree with your ears anyways.
So there's social interaction right from
the beginning,
but for the point of simplification,
you might say,
well first the child organized this
themselves into a functional unity under
the pressure of social dynamics.
And then they get unified enough so that
they can attain unity with another child
by setting up a fictional world and
cooperating and competing within that.
Because that's quite interesting to a
because you know,
people often juxtapose cooperation and
competition as if they're opposites,
but that they're not opposites at all.
In another Piagetian observation.
So you say,
well there's hockey,
a competitive game.
And people would say,
well yeah,
but then you think,
well really,
really no one brings a basketball,
right?
So we're going to play by the rules.
That's cooperation.
Well,
are the teams competing against each
other?
Well,
yes,
but they agree to compete within a
particular landscape and they all
cooperate to maintain that landscape.
And so you do the same thing when you're
playing monopoly.
It's like you're trying to win,
but at the same time you're cooperating.
That's what,
that's.
That's society man.
That's society right there.
You're cooperating,
that's the big enclosure.
And within that there are regulated
competitions,
but to separate those artificially and
say,
well,
one's come competition.
And the others cooperation has just.
It's just,
it's just not very smart.
It's not observant.
That isn't how it works and,
and Games are intensely cooperative.
Even if they're intensely competitive.
I mean the hockey teams are playing the
same game.
That's the cooperation.
Then each team,
there's competition within the team to
be the best player let's say,
but everyone wants that because everyone
wants good players to emerge,
but you still cooperate like mad with
your teammates and if you don't pass
and,
and you know,
play like a reasonable person,
then they're going to not be happy with
you.
And so even within that competition,
cooperation is regulating the
interactions and then you can think this
is a really good thing to think too.
It's like,
you know,
people often say to their kids,
it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose,
it's how you play the game.
And the kid who of course has no idea
what that means.
It's like,
what do you mean,
ah,
I'm trying to win.
And the parents says,
no,
it matters how you play and the kid
pushes them and the parents really can't
come up with a good explanation of why
that's the case.
They might say,
well,
other kids won't play with you if you're
there you go,
because you could say this is something
to think about.
So there's a game and there's a victory
within the game,
but then there's the set of all games
and there's victory across the set of
all games and the victory that you
attained across the set of all games
isn't winning all the games.
It's being invited to play all the
games.
And so if you play fair,
then you're playing a metagame and the
metagame is how to win across the set of
all games.
And so if you teach your child how to
behave properly,
then they always get invited to play and
that makes them winners.
And that's that.
And so if you understand that,
you understand something phenomenally
important about the emergence of
morality,
you know,
because people moral relativists in
particular think that morality is
relative,
you know,
and of course human beings are diverse,
just like languages are diverse and
there's more than one playable game,
but there's not really more than one
playable metagame.
It's like you're either the kind of
person that other people want to play
with or you're not,
and if you're not the kind of person
that other people want to play with,
then you're a loser.
It's as simple as that,
and that's true of all cultures.
They might be playing different
individual games within their culture.
Undoubtedly they are,
but the set of all games that they play
is still common across cultures.
That's part of what makes us human.
And then you could say as well,
we're actually evolved to detect people
who are good at playing the set of all
possible games and we actually know that
that's not theoretical.
We know,
for example,
some things are easy to remember and
some things are hard to remember.
You know,
here's something that's easy to
remember.
You play with someone in need,
cheat man.
You will remember that.
That's like in your mind that's not
going anywhere.
And so you're great at detecting
cheaters and you remember and that's
because you can't trust a cheater and
you shouldn't invite a cheater to play a
game with you because they might cheat.
And so that's part of the innate
morality system.
You remember cheaters because they
aren't good at playing the metagame.
And of course your evolved,
of course you're adapted to the metagame
because you're the product of this
immense evolutionary history,
right?
And whoever your ancestors were,
which is an unbroken string of
successful reproducers going back three
and a half billion years,
you think about that,
every single one of your ancestors
successfully reproduced it's mind
boggling,
the chances against that are so it's
billions,
billions to one.
And here you are,
the line of three and a half billion
years of success.
The whole world was trying to kill you
that whole time.
And here you are.
It's like,
and but you know,
you're still only gonna last about eight
years.
So,
but that's,
you know,
still,
good for you.
So anyways,
there were lots of games that your
ancestors were playing across that
immense span of time.
Many,
many,
you know,
Lizard Games and tree dweller games and,
and,
and what,
and Crustacean Games,
you know,
that huge set of games and you're
adapted to win across those games.
All of them.
And that's built into you,
man,
that's,
that's your central human nature.
That's what makes you social.
And it's not some mirror cultural
construct.
Quite the contrary.
It's,
it's so deeply embedded in you.
It's what you are.
Alright.
So,
well this is a story.
It's a game too.
That's another way of thinking about it.
You know,
like that's a monopoly game.
Well,
what's the frame while that's the rules
of the game and are they,
why do you accept them?
Well,
it's kind of arbitrary,
right?
It's like that happens to be the rules.
Hockey has different rules,
basketball has different rules,
but what they share is that they have
rules.
Okay.
So there's a frame that's the rules.
And then within the frame there's a goal
and the goal is whatever the rules
dictate,
you know,
there's usually,
it's usually the construction of a
hierarchy of success within a frame.
And so that's what you play.
And so you play monopoly and it's like,
well we'll accept the rules.
That's the social contract.
And then we'll each try to win.
And that'll be fun.
We find that amusing.
And if you lose,
what do you say?
Why you say,
well,
there's always said another game and so
that's great.
So if you have that attitude and you
play fair,
then it doesn't matter that much that
you,
whether you win or lose,
although you still want to try to win
because otherwise you're not a good
player,
but you accept defeat gracefully because
you can play again and so and you'll win
some and you lose some.
And so that's not so bad,
you know,
and even if you lose,
well maybe you learn something and,
and you're doing a lot more than one
thing while you're playing monopoly,
you know,
you're having a conversation and
learning how to interact with people and
learning how to regulate your emotions.
And so even if you lose,
if you have any sense,
you win.
And if your kids have any sense,
they know that and so that way you
buffer them against defeat.
It's like,
yeah,
I get them next time.
It's like,
so okay,
you should try,
but it's okay.
And,
and that's,
that's,
that's useful information for people to
know.
So.
Alright.
So you're always in one of these little
frameworks and there's just no getting
out of it.
So,
and that's because,
you know,
at any given moment,
this is like,
it's like field theory.
There used to be psychological theories
that talked about the field of human
experience,
something like that.
And this is kind of what that is.
This is a field.
And basically what happens is you parse
out a little part of the world say,
and so you can handle.
So let's say it has some duration.
You're not aiming at something 50 years
in the future.
It's because how the hell are you going
to do that?
You,
there's too many variables,
you know,
so you're aiming at some handleable
amount of time and you pause it,
a goal in there and you plot your route
and then that tells you what's up and
tells you what's down because up moves
you towards the goal and down moves you
away from the goal.
And that sets up your motivational
framework so that you have some worth
attaining.
You know,
that's a really interesting thing to
know too.
It's like why have a goal?
While it's easy,
no goal,
no positive emotion,
because you experienced positive emotion
by noticing that you're moving towards a
goal and so if you don't have to have a
goal while you can't have any positive
emotion,
so you better have a goal,
and so you might say,
well,
what should the goal be?
Well,
we could start by saying,
well,
any goal is better than none,
and then we might say,
well,
it should be a goal that other people
will let you pursue because otherwise
it's gonna be kind of difficult and
maybe there'll be even happy to help you
pursue it.
That would even be better and maybe it's
a goal that would enable you to learn
how to pursue other goals while you
pursue that goal.
Boy,
that would really be good,
and so you can see that your goal is
parameterized,
but that doesn't mean that any old goal
works.
It means there's some goals that were
nicely and some not so nicely.
There are playable games and non
playable games.
That's a good way of thinking about it
and you want to have a playable game and
there's a lot of them.
Lawyer,
plumber,
you know,
actor,
whatever,
they're playable games and,
and it's not obvious which ones better,
but it's certainly obvious which ones
are sustainable and which ones are worth
and so there's a set of playable games
and you need to extract from that set of
playable games,
a game that suits you and that would be
partly due to your temperament,
you know,
because extroverted people want to play
an extroverted game and highly neurotic
people want to play a safe game and
agreeable people want to play a generous
game and disagreeable people wanting to
play a game that's highly competitive so
they can win and you know,
fine,
but they're all within the realm of
playable gates and that means they're
socially acceptable as well.
And so that means it isn't just
arbitrary,
it isn't just relative what you decide
to do.
It's heavily parameterized.
There's only,
there's a set of playable games and it's
large.
The set is large,
but it,
there are commonalities within it.
And that's why there are commonalities.
That's why morality has a common basis
fundamentally.
And so that's partly what we're trying
to investigate is like what's up?
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
Is there such a thing?
Now,
one thing to remember is that if you
don't have direct a hierarchical
structure with to he matt,
you got no positive motivation because
you experience positive motivation in
relationship to a goal,
not from attaining the goal,
that satisfaction and besides it's
fleeting.
You know perfectly well,
you graduate from university,
Poof,
next day you have a problem which is
what do you do next?
And that's a,
that's a tough problem.
So it's not like you've solved your
problems.
By winning that game,
you just introduced the problem of
having to introduce another game.
So it's unreliable as a source of
positive emotion.
But what's reliable is you set a goal
and you try to attain it and then that
gives your life.
That literally provides your life with
meaning.
That's what meaning is.
Now it's more than that,
but that's,
that's what it is.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well,
what's a really good goal?
Well,
that's what we're trying to figure out.
What's a really good goal?
And now,
okay,
so you got that.
So now I'm going to walk through at
least partly through,
we'll see how far we get.
I'm going to walk through Pinocchio with
you because that's what the movie's
about and it's,
uh,
it's hard to say how it came about.
Like it was written the story by a guy
named cody I,
c o l l O v I,
and it's quite a bit different.
The story,
that story,
the written one from the Disney version,
the Disney version was a product of the
collaboration of geniuses,
of animation essentially.
So they were artistic geniuses,
great at capturing motion and emotion
and all of that be stellar at that and
imaginative,
tremendously imaginative,
but collectively imaginative.
And so they put together a collective
product and you might say,
well,
how did they do that?
Exactly?
It's like,
well,
they were good storytellers.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means you don't want the story that
works and the story that doesn't.
And maybe partly what you do is you kind
of think out a story and you think,
well,
what if this happens?
Well,
maybe this should happen.
Oh,
that's the thing.
that would work.
It's like the little flash of
inspiration,
right?
It's like you got a piece of the puzzle
that fits you think,
yeah,
that would work there,
and then you talk to the other people
and you generate ideas and someone says,
well,
what if.
What if they do this?
And everyone goes now,
now that's just not believable.
No one's going to buy that,
and someone else has a little
revelation.
They said,
well,
you know,
it makes some sense somehow with if they
do this,
and everybody goes,
oh yeah,
that,
that really,
that really works.
It's like,
why?
Why?
You don't know.
You don't know why it works,
but it works because it works because
it's the right story.
And so what does that mean?
Well,
it's kind of associated with this
metagame idea.
You know,
it's like there's a story that you
should be acting out that works across
games and you have an inkling of it.
You have a notion of it.
You have a vague apprehension of it.
It's sort of built into that's
archetype,
that's an archetype.
And so then when you read a story that
works,
you're just entranced by it and you all
know that you go to a movie and it's a
great movie and it's like you're just
blown away.
You know,
it's a movie,
can pull you in and turn you into one of
the screen characters and like run you
through a huge set of emotions.
I saw this movie once about South
America.
It started with this guy running out of
a subway naked and he didn't know where
he was and it turned out that he had
been absconded by the totalitarian death
squads and he couldn't remember anything
about himself.
And he went back to his village.
And basically what happened was that he
ended up back in the totalitarian death
grip.
And it was.
It showed how the fascist state had
saturated the village completely.
And so it was a tragedy.
And you could see with every action that
this guy,
this amnestic guy,
as he recreated him himself and
remembered his identity,
was going to travel down exactly the
same road because nothing had changed.
And by the time I wish I've looked for
what that movie was for years,
I've never been able to find it again.
But when the movie was over,
every single person in the theater was
crying and not just a little bit.
It was like they were just out of it.
It was brilliant,
terrifying movie.
And that meant there was some write
about it man.
And it got people and you might say,
you know,
you have dim apprehensions about the
world and some of those are instinctual
and some of them are a consequence of
your,
of your experience.
And it's like the pieces are fragmented.
But if you get away from them a long
way,
as you could see how they fit together,
but they're fragmented.
And then you go see a story and those
pieces go click,
click,
click.
And you think,
wow,
that's what,
that's how that works out.
That's,
that's what that means.
And that produces that overwhelming
emotion.
And,
and that's partly how you make yourself
transparent to yourself.
You know,
you go experience the story,
who watched the story,
you tell a story and you start to find
out who you are by doing that.
My nephew had a dream at one point
someone made a little animated thing out
of it and put it on the intranet,
which is quite cool.
So anyways,
he,
he was having night terrors and he ran
around like a little night,
uh,
you know,
Kai,
Connecticut,
k and Igh t night,
and he had little,
you know,
armor and a sword and he run around the
house with little white hat on being the
night.
And he was only like four or something.
And he'd watched his lot of Disney
movies,
lot of movies.
So he kinda got the night idea was,
it was at his acting that out and he was
having these terrorists at night.
Right.
And so he'd go to bed with his little
night hat and his sword and he put them
on is bad.
And then at night he'd wake up
screaming.
And that happened for a very long time.
And so when I went to visit,
uh,
you know,
I found out that this was happening and
he had a night terror,
so the kid wakes up with night terrors
screaming but can't remember anything
generally speaking.
So anyways,
this was happening.
And so what happened one day?
And I was sitting with him and his
family at the,
at the breakfast table,
and I said,
uh,
did you,
did he have a dream?
And he said,
Oh yes,
I had a dream.
I said,
well,
you know,
what was your dream?
And He,
and he said,
well,
I was out on this field and,
and,
and I was surrounded by these dwarfs.
And they came up to my knees and they
were,
they didn't have any arms,
they had big feet and they were covered
with hair and there was a cross shaved
at the top of their head and they were
all greasy and they had huge beaks.
And everywhere I went they jumped at me
with their beaks and there was lots of
them.
And everybody was very quiet after he
said this because it was like that,
oh,
that's why you're screaming at night.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
and so,
so and,
and,
and then he said,
but,
but at the background there was a dragon
and the dragon would blow out smoke and
fire and then it would turn into these
dwarfs.
So it's like,
man,
that kid had a problem,
right?
It was like,
well,
what are you gonna do you fight off a
dwarf?
Who Cares?
It's like puff 10 more.
That's life,
man.
That's life.
Really.
That's the Hydra.
You cut off one head,
seven more grow.
That's life snakes everywhere and you
get rid of one,
there'll be more.
And so he figured that out.
It's a hell of an existential shock when
you're four.
And so he's like,
he's a knight.
He's thinking,
what do I do about these dwarfs while
there's too many of them,
but there's a dragon also.
So I said,
well,
what could you do about that?
Right?
Loaded question.
It implies that you could do something
about that.
Well,
he kind of knew that which is why he was
running around like a night and he kind
of figured out and he said,
well,
I get my dad and I jump up on the dragon
and I poke out both of its size with my
sword and then I go right down in
stomach to the place where the fire came
out,
the firebox and then I carve a piece of
the firebox out at.
I'd make a shield and that would be the
end of that.
And I thought,
wow,
good work kid.
Like you really got it right.
It's the,
it's the central human story.
There's the terrible unknown,
right?
Fire-Breathing generating trouble.
And what do you do?
You confront that,
you confront that and by confronting it
you get stronger.
That's the shield and that's,
that's what a human being is and that's,
that's right.
It's exactly right.
And that was the end of his night
terrors by the way,
which seems too good to be true,
but it is actually true because I
followed up with his mother for a long
time and that was that.
He catalyzed that part of his identity.
He adopted the role of the mythological
hero and that's what he needed to do
because like there was lots of drag.
There's a dragon and a bunch of dwarfs.
Like,
what the hell are you going to do about
that?
That's not going to help.
You know,
if you run into dream like that,
the doors multiply and they get bigger
and you get smaller as you run.
It's like that's not a good.
That is not a good solution.
And people do that in their life all the
time.
And so the dwarves get bigger until
they're giants and they get smaller
until there's nothing left of them.
And then,
then there's no recovery.
That is not good.
No.
Okay.
So now.
Alright.
Also propose to you that there there's a
symbolic structure to the world.
It's a metal structure.
I would say.
I think these categories are truly real
and they're there basically this,
there's unexplored territory.
There's explored territory and there's
you and unexplored territory is the
source of great riches and it probably
will kill you and explored.
Territory is your culture and it
crunches you into submission and
conformity and turns you into a
civilized being and you're stuck with
both of those and then there's you and
you know you're kind of admirable and
cool and you do a lot of decent,
wonderful,
amazing things and there's things about
you that are just horrible and you're
and you know about them and you're stuck
with them and that's the world and
that's the,
that's the landscape of the world.
And what you'll see if you pay attention
is that people who aren't ideologues
like Rousseau or say like hobbs,
but it doesn't matter,
idiot logs will tell you part of that
story.
So environmentalist's for example,
we'll say nature,
that's pristine beauty,
natural harmony,
a French landscape,
be it,
it's a paradise,
especially if there are no people.
It's a paradise.
And then culture is a rapacious monster,
and human beings driving that culture
against nature are
monsters of a sort that,
and perhaps
there should be fewer of them.
It's like,
yeah,
that's all true.
Exactly.
Dead.
Dead on.
Right on.
Exactly right.
Um,
is that movie called Avatar?
Yes.
That's James Cameron's movie,
right?
That's that story.
Yeah.
And uh,
hey,
it's good story.
It's even a mythological story,
but it's only half the story.
The other story,
you could think about it as a frontier
myth that star trek or star wars for
that better mostly star Trek.
It's like,
but we'll,
we'll put it in context to the frontier
myth.
The myth that drew settlers into America
say it's,
well,
there's a wild savage landscape out
there that can be conquered by unsettled
and stabilized by civilization and it'll
be the heroic pioneer who does it.
It's exactly the opposite story of the
environmental story,
which is actually why I think the
environmental story of eventually
emerged.
It was the frontier story called how to
lack and it missed half of the world.
And so the other story I had to come up
and it did,
and if you take both of those stories,
even though they're exactly opposite to
one another,
if you know both of those stories,
then you know the whole story and it's
really weird,
you know,
because one of the propositions of
formal logic is it's a fundamental
proposition is that something can't be
itself and its opposite at the same
time.
It's like that's true for some sorts of
things.
It's true for logical claims,
but it's completely wrong in this
particular situation because things are
that what they are and they're opposite
at the same time.
And that makes it very,
very difficult to.
That's why a dragon hordes gold.
It's like,
what's up with that?
Well,
it'll eat you and it will,
but it has gold.
Well,
so what do you do about that?
Because it's,
it's,
it's paradoxical demands.
Well,
what you want to do is face the dragon
and get the damn goal.
That's what you want to do.
Well,
you have to be a paradoxical being even
to do that.
So,
you know,
in,
in the Hobbit,
for example,
when,
what's his name,
Frodo,
right,
isn't,
it's not,
or it's Bilbo,
Bilbo in the Harvard,
you know,
he's kind of this little underdeveloped
overprotected shire dweller and he's
called on a great adventure to go and
find the dragon and he has to become a
thief in order to manage it.
Well,
that's pretty weird,
you know,
it's like,
well,
it's,
it's because as a good citizen,
he's just not enough to conquer a
dragon.
He asked to also become a bad citizen in
some sense.
He has to incorporate the part of
themselves that's monstrous,
let's say,
and develop that and hone it.
And that's to say that,
well,
if you are harmless,
you're not virtuous,
you're just harmless.
You're like a rabbit.
Rabbit isn't virtuous.
It's just,
just can't do anything except get eaten.
It's not virtuous.
If you're a monster and you don't act
monstrously,
then you're virtuous.
But you also have to be a monster while
you see this all the time.
Harry Potter's like that too.
It's like he's,
he's flawed,
he's hurt.
He's got evil in him.
He can talk to snakes.
Man,
he breaks rules all the time,
all the time.
He's not an obedient at all,
but you know,
he has a good reason for breaking the
rules and if he couldn't break the
rules,
him and his little clique of rule
breaking,
you know,
troublemakers.
If they didn't break the rules,
they wouldn't attain the highest goal.
So it's very peculiar,
but it's very,
very.
It's a very,
very,
very common mythological notion.
You know,
the hero has to be,
the hero has to be a monster,
but a controlled monster.
Batman is like that,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's everywhere.
It's tour story.
You always hear meaning.
We have to be more precise.
Well,
that's a good,
that's a good question because one
question is,
you know,
you're kind of implicitly moral insofar
as you're socialized,
but that's sort of procedural.
It's just built into you.
This is different.
This is also becoming conscious of it
and expanding out your personality into
dimensions that it wouldn't normally
occupy.
So this happens to people all the time.
So for example,
lots of my clients,
my clinical clients are too agreeable
and I'm,
they're generally women because women
are more agreeable than men,
but not always because I've had
agreeable man,
his clients as well,
and what happens is they're resentful
and they don't know how to stand up for
themselves and it's because they're very
compassionate by nature.
And so if you're entering into a
negotiation with them,
they'll let you win.
Well,
that's not so good because you know you
need to win too.
Especially if you're in an organization
of adults where there's,
there's a struggle,
right?
When you have kids,
you can let them win,
especially infants like you have to let
them win and that's partly why
compassion is so necessary.
But as a,
as a basis for negotiation between
adults,
it's like,
sorry,
it's insufficient.
You have to.
You have to be a bit of a monster so
that you can say no.
And so a lot of what you do in
psychotherapy is treat people's anxiety
and depression.
That's a huge chunk of it.
Help them straighten out the way they
think.
That's a huge chunk of it,
but another chunk of it is,
well,
let's toughen you up.
You know,
let's put you in a position where you
can bargain,
let's teach you how to assert yourself
and stand up for yourself and that's
assertiveness training and it's a huge
chunk of psychotherapy and you need to.
You need to learn it.
It's like because part of how you
regulate your interactions with other
people to negotiate and you cannot
negotiate unless you can say no,
you can't do it,
and its causes conflict to say no,
and if you don't like conflict,
which is basically the definition of
being agreeable,
then you can't tolerate the conflict and
so then you can't negotiate on your own
behalf and so then you keep losing and
you're bullied and you know it's,
it's not good.
Then you get resentful and,
and it's really not good.
So you have to develop your inner
monster a little bit and,
and then that makes you a better person.
Not a worst person.
It's weird.
It's weird,
but,
but that's just how it is outside of
that diagram is chaos itself and that's
the chaos from which things emerge.
Now,
I can't tell you much about that yet
because it's too damn complicated,
but I think the best way to think about
chaos is as potential.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's also that place you end up when you
don't know what to do.
It's the source of all things,
but it's also the terrible Predator,
the terrible eternal Predator that lurks
beyond the explored domain.
It's a winged dragon and it's weighing
who knows why matter and spirit.
That's partly what it is and I'll
explain that later.
It's also potentially the predatory
beast that's been after us for for
forever and the winged Predator that
picked us up from the sky.
So primates,
for example,
monkeys have some monkeys have three
specialized alarm cries,
one is for snakes,
and that usually means hit the trees and
then one's for leopards and that means
hit the trees and go out on a skinny
branch because the leopard can't get to
you.
And then there's one for like birds of
prey,
which means hide somewhere on the ground
so that you don't get picked off.
And it's like,
well,
that's what that is.
That's what that is.
And that's chaos.
And it's expanded into much more than
that.
And then I showed you,
I don't remember if I showed you this,
but this is.
This is a symbolic representation of
mother nature for their culture and the
suffering individual.
But it's all that's all positive.
There's no negative elements there,
but that's okay.
That's a partial representation.
And those things are sacred in some
sense because they are representative of
an ultimate reality of an ultimate
reality.
The sacrificial individual hear the
suffering individual.
Well,
that's pretty straightforward.
It's like
that's what,
that's life,
that's suffering,
that's what happens to the individual.
And so everyone is looking at that.
There's a.
It has power,
that idea.
Well,
it's because you know,
culture supports the suffering,
individual cultures nested inside
benevolent nature.
And that's part of the story of the
world.
And this part of the story we're trying
to figure out and make articulate.
We'd been doing that for thousands of
years trying to make this story
articulate and it's not yet articulate
it.
It's only we're only getting it.
We're only getting it and we.
We basically do that now mostly with
movies and stories and fiction and that
sort of thing.
We still don't have it articulated.
I think young when he came closer than
anyone else,
young and an Eric Norman who was one of
his students,
came closer than anyone else ever has to
actually articulate about and that's
what you and was trying to do,
is to take all these images,
archetipal images,
instinctual images and say,
well,
what do they mean?
What do they mean?
And he got a long ways on that.
Although his writing is quite obscure
and it's obscured because how the hell
are you going to explain an image like
that without being obscure?
It's like it's insanely complicated and
it's not linear.
It's not a linear thing that that's why
it's in a picture because a picture
presents everything at once and you want
to take that apart linearly.
Jesus,
it's just,
it's just impossible,
but we've been struggling to do that.
Really.
We'd been struggling to do that from the
time we became self conscious,
you know,
what is the world about?
How should we live in it?
While that's a partial answer,
and it's a culture bound answer
obviously,
but you see archetypal representations
like this and many cultures,
so for example,
the image of the Virgin and child that
way predates Christianity.
Like the Egyptians,
that was isis and horace.
That goes back.
Whoa.
We have no idea how far thousands and
thousands of years before the emergence
of Judaism and Christianity way back
before that and no doubt back into
prehistory itself because a culture that
doesn't hold the mother and child as
sacred dies obviously because obviously
so it has to be held as it has to be
held as something that you revere,
which at least means you don't kill
mothers and children and at least means
that.
And that's an instinct.
You know,
it's an instinct and violates you to do
that.
And thank God.
All right,
let's take 15 minutes.
So I told you about this a little bit
last week,
but you know,
one of the motivations I had for
thinking the things that I've thought
through the motivation I had for
thinking them through was because,
well,
I,
it,
it seemed self evident to me,
let's say,
and I think that was partly from reading
you but not that just helped me clarify,
was that it was sort of humans
contention that we had an organic
development of a metaphysical ethic that
was embedded in,
in religious tradition and that
basically unfolded,
let's say in the West until about 1600,
1500,
something like that.
And then science emerged and we got
unbelievably technologically powerful
art and using a certain view of the
world.
You know,
we're so technologically powerful but
we're still not very wise and that just
seems to me to be a bad combination.
And I thought about that a lot.
It's like,
okay,
well how do you handle the combination
of exceptional technological power and
and an impaired ethic,
let's say something like that under
developed ethic or one even in which you
have no faith because you know it,
it seems that the foundational elements
of it are irrational.
They're there in mythology,
there in religion,
they don't fit well with the scientific
worldview.
How do you rectify that problem?
And while that's a tough problem,
you know,
it's a crazy problem and certainly it
was the problem that young was trying to
address.
There's no doubt about it.
And along with that,
with an associated problem which,
which was,
you know,
what happened in the 20th century,
which was so awful and in so many
places,
it was just so unbelievably brutal and
terrible and it was perpetrated by
millions of people and they were
individual people and they weren't that
much different from normal people.
In fact,
they were normal people.
And so the other thing that struck me
was that it would be better if that sort
of thing didn't happen anymore.
And so I was trying to figure out what
the hell could possibly be done about
that and you know,
part of humans contention was while you
had to understand yourself as a monster,
if you were ever going to maintain some
control over the fact that you are in
fact the monster and that that could
come forth if the situation is correct.
It's like,
okay,
that seems reasonable and so,
well it seemed to me that,
you know,
people had to become wiser and of course
that's a very difficult thing to figure
out because you can even question
whether there is such a thing as wisdom,
you know?
And,
and then I thought,
well that's what the universities are
supposed to do.
Especially the humanities mostly in
particular,
it's supposed to make you wise.
That's what it's for.
And it's doing a terrible job of that.
In my estimation.
It's,
it's more decimating people as far as I
can tell and undermining whatever ethic
they have rather than making people
wise.
And.
But I think that we have to become wise.
I don't think there a choice.
I think it's a matter of survival and
it's more than that because if you're
wise in your own life,
you're going to have a way better life
like incomparably better because you're.
You're gonna sleep soundly with a good
conscience at night and you know people
say that's worth more than money and
that's worth more than money.
I know lots of people who have lots of
money and let me tell you,
money protects you.
Your as well protected from the world by
money right now as you ever will be for
the rest of your life because there's
most of life's fundamental problems
can't be solved with money.
You know,
like rich people get divorced.
They have affairs.
Their children get sick that they have
all the problems you have and that's
partly because you're already rich and
so
you might think that if you had a bunch
more money,
things would be better,
but it's just not true.
In fact,
in some ways that they might be worse
because money can open up,
can open up the possibility of all sorts
of temptations to you that you just
can't afford at the moment.
So well.
So like economic economics,
we've already solved that problem
fundamentally and we're rapidly solving
it everywhere in the world,
right?
I mean,
the world economy is growing so damn
fast that you can't even imagine how you
could possibly make it grow any faster.
It's crazy.
We've lifted hundreds of millions of
people out of poverty in the last 15
years.
You know,
the UN set a goal by 2015,
I think it was to cut poverty by half if
I remember correctly.
And they reached it two years early,
you know,
it's like,
it's unbelievable.
So.
Well.
So then I started to try to understand
what it might be to,
to live and,
and really what I was looking forward to
was not so much to live a life that was
wise,
but at least to live a life that wasn't
pathologically unwise and I thought of
the sorts of things that people were
doing to one another in Auschwitz camps
and in the Gulag archipelago and all of
that horror that was perpetrated on,
on people as definitely unwise.
Whatever else you might say about it.
It was unwise.
And so then I thought,
well,
maybe there's a way to figure out how
you could not do that.
And so that's,
and I think that that's my sense is that
when you come to university to learn how
to be a civilized person,
which is what supposed to happen at
university,
otherwise it's just a trade school and
you might as well go to trade school as
far as I'm concerned.
If you want to learn something that will
get you a job,
it's like it's a lot faster and it's
more certain and,
and it's useful.
If you're not being taught to be a
citizen at university,
then
why bother with it so well.
So that's what we're trying to figure
out.
And,
and that's part of that cloud of
mythological fantasy that surrounds our
culture.
That's it's part of it's deep history
that we're trying to grapple with the
humanities and with art and all of that,
that you're trying to.
You're trying to master and incorporate
and,
and pull into you so that you're
situated properly in history and,
and you're not just floating in the void
of,
you know,
this tiny individuality that's divorced
from everything else.
You're weak in that circumstance.
Alright.
So
that's more of an explanation of why I'm
trying to puzzle through these things
and trying to puzzle through them with
you.
So anyways,
we talked about this,
this,
this song last week.
And you know,
I,
I made a hypothesis to you.
We'll go through this quickly.
Um,
it's Doggerel,
it's not great poetry,
but it's irrelevant.
Um,
it was a very popular song.
It's quite beautiful in the movie.
It's actually sung by like a heavenly
choir.
That's what it sounds like.
So it's got this cathedral.
You could imagine people singing it in a
cathedral essentially.
And so that's not accidental.
It's purposeful,
you know,
it,
it partakes of that,
what would you call it?
It,
it partakes of that aesthetic,
that,
that's,
that's it.
So the filmmakers are are implying that
what is about to be shown to you has
this divine element essentially,
and that that's signified by the choir
of voices that sings the song and the
song says so fundamentally something
like this is that if you lift up your
eyes above the temporal,
into the transcendent,
and so that's what exists in the
heavenly world.
In the stars.
If you pick a,
an ultimate goal,
if you pick the right ultimate goal,
then anyone can do this.
That's the other thing.
It's democratic.
It's anyone can do this.
So that's the second proposition.
It doesn't matter who you are,
you can do this.
And so I think that's a reflection of
the idea of the divinity of the
individual.
It's like there's something about each
individual that's valuable regardless of
their idiosyncrasies and and so they
have this potential that they can
manifest.
And how do you manifest it?
You pick the right goal and what's the
right goal?
Well,
it's,
it's high,
it's elevated,
it's above the mundane.
Now what does that mean?
Well,
you don't really know.
You don't really know.
That's why it signified by a star and a
star is something that glimmers in the
night,
right?
So it's a source of light in the
darkness and so there's a metaphor
there.
Obviously there's a metaphor there and
the star is the star,
that star of Hollywood,
you know the person that you emulate.
That's part of it because it's an ideal
is going to be a human ideal of some
sort that you're aiming out and so the
ideal human being is,
is the star that you're aiming at.
Maybe it's something like that.
If that's what you're aiming at,
you might say,
well,
what should you aim out in life?
And wanting to answer as well,
why don't you aim at being whatever you
could be.
That would be the best.
No,
you don't know what that is exactly
because how do you know?
You know,
but you could think,
well that would be really good if I
could have it.
And then you could say,
well,
can I think of anything better than
that?
And if the answer is no,
then well why not go for that?
You know?
And you might say,
well,
it's too ambitious,
it takes too much responsibility.
It's like,
yeah,
that,
those are definitely problems.
And one of the things that I've figured
out over the years is that if you
offered the person the opportunity,
you know,
because people say,
well,
life doesn't really have any ultimate
meaning.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fine.
So fine.
Let's say it has an ultimate meaning,
but that in order to experience that
ultimate meaning,
you have to take on ultimate
responsibility for what you do.
Well,
that's a heavy price to pay,
to have a meaningful life.
You know?
And you might say,
well,
there's no damn way I'm going to do
that.
I'll just go for the pointless.
I'll go for that.
The trivial pointless perspective,
which you know was kind of hard on me
existentially,
but it frees me up.
I can do whatever the hell I want moment
to moment.
I don't have any ultimate
responsibility.
And so then you think,
well that's kind of a good deal.
And then then.
But that raises this weird specter of
doubt,
which is why when you hear people talk
about the ultimate futility of life,
is it because life is ultimately futile
or is it because they've decided that
they would just as soon not adopt the
responsibility and they use that real
decision,
which is to not adopt the
responsibility.
They rationalize that by proposing that
life is ultimately meaningful,
meaningless,
and like,
you know,
I kind of by that I really do think
that's what's going on.
So,
but maybe not.
But it could be that if you want to have
an ultimately meaningful life that you
have to adopt ultimate responsibility.
Makes Sense.
What might that mean?
Well,
one thing it might mean is that,
and I do think it means this is it.
I think it was Alexander Pope,
but I might be wrong about that.
Who said nothing human is foreign to me.
And that's a hell of a statement,
right?
Because if you think about all the
things that human beings are capable of,
they're capable of some,
like if you really want to know what
people are capable of,
you should read about read about unit
seven slash 31,
but I would not recommend it because if
you read it,
you will never forget it and you will be
sorry that you read it,
but you'll know anyways to say that
nothing human is foreign to you.
That's a hell of a thing to say because
that means that what other people have
done you could do.
And that also means you need to take
responsibility for that.
That's no joke.
You know,
it's a big deal to do that and even the
trivial manner anyways.
So the idea is that you can elevate.
If you elevate your viewpoint to some
transcendent ethic,
you want what's ultimately good.
You really want that.
Whatever that is you don't know,
but that's what you're even out says
that,
well then it says this strange thing
well,
what you want,
we'll all of a sudden come to you.
Well,
that's a proposition.
The proposition that's basically played
out in the movie,
it's a hypothesis,
the hypothesis is the best way to Orient
yourself in life is to orient yourself
towards the highest good that you're
capable of imagining and then aim at
that and then things will work out the
best way they can for you.
And I think,
I believe that's correct.
My,
my observation of life has led me to see
that that seems to be correct.
So for example,
you don't get something you don't aim at
that just doesn't work out and so lots
of people are not thinking that's what
they get.
So if you aim at something,
you have a reasonable crack at getting
it,
you know,
you tend to change what you're aiming at
a bed along the way because like what
are,
you know,
the aim there,
you're wrong but you get a little closer
and then the aim there and you're still
wrong.
You get a little closer to the aim there
and you know as you move towards what
you're aiming at,
your,
your characterization of what to aim at
becomes more and more sophisticated.
And so it doesn't really matter if
you're wrong to begin with,
as long as you're smart enough to learn
on the way and as long as you specify a
goal.
So I specify a vague what I want things
to be the best they could be,
and I'm willing to learn what best means
as I go along.
Okay?
So fine.
And then you get what you truly need
will say,
well,
maybe not know if your heart is in your
dream.
What does that mean?
Well,
that to me reflects this idea of a kind
of integrated viewpoint.
One of the things young proposed was
that as you,
as you integrate yourself
psychologically,
what happens is that your rationality
integrates with your emotions.
They stopped being opposed forces like
the enlightenment ideas.
That rationality and desire are
opposites and enemies in a sense.
And the young Ian notion is,
and the psychoanalytic notion,
I would say in general and the humanist
notion even perhaps is the thought
that's not right.
What you want to do is you want to
integrate irrationality with your
emotions and your motivations.
They're not separable even in
technically they have to work together
and that all has to be integrated with
your body.
Not only do you have to take your,
your heart into account and notice what
it is that you want and don't want,
but you also have to embody that.
You have to act that out in the world.
So fine.
So that's what that means.
And if you do that,
then well then your horizons open up.
And I also believe that's true.
You know,
I've known people in my life who were
insanely successful,
like insanely successful and those
people are like,
they're there,
are pretty damn together about,
you know,
like they're tough,
smart,
strategic,
generous,
you know,
they're always given people
opportunities,
honest,
like they've got it all and oh,
and,
and sometimes they're not.
Now I'm not saying that everyone who's
wildly successful is wildly successful
because they've got themselves together,
but you know,
because there are crooks and you know,
there are people who gained status one
way or another by nefarious means.
But that's a lot more unstable than you
might think.
And I can't say exactly if that,
if pursue that route,
you're going to pay for it,
like you'll have your money or whatever
it is,
but it's not gonna do much good for you.
So and so it does seem to me to be the
people that have integrated themselves
and that and that are pursuing a noble
goal,
high goal,
who,
who actually are able to do remarkable
things and remarkable things can be done
at every level.
You know,
it isn't like you'd have to change the
world as a whole.
It could be that you do something
remarkable within your family,
you know,
and that's,
that can be tremendously admirable.
You know,
someone's got to take care of a family
member if they're sick,
you know,
like there's,
there's heroic acts that you can
undertake in the local environment.
And maybe that will go on an heralded,
let's say.
But that doesn't mean that it isn't
remarkable.
I mean,
I've met people who are so damaged,
you just can't imagine it.
And,
and yet,
well,
one person I met when I was at in
Montreal was this woman and she was just
ruined,
man.
She,
she looked like a street person and she
was so shy,
she couldn't even look at you like she
basically looked at the ground because
it was like there was light emanating
from everyone else and she was way too
timid and humbled to even bear it,
you know,
and partly what I was doing was trying
to get her to straighten up and not look
so street person because it wasn't going
very well for her in social
interactions,
you know.
But it turned out that that isn't what
she came to the behavior therapy unit
four.
And she had her,
I think she lived with her attitude was
like schizophrenia.
And,
and then her aunt's boyfriend was an
alcoholic who like went on long
harangues about the devil and it's like
really mad and she wasn't bright.
This woman,
she really wasn't.
And,
and,
um,
you know,
she didn't really have a job and it was
just like,
it was just not good in every way.
And then she also had this unbelievable
humility and,
but then,
you know,
it turned out what she wanted.
I just couldn't bloody well believe
this,
that she had this dog and she used to
walk it around.
She took care of the dog and now you
know,
that was a good thing and she'd actually
been an inpatient at the Douglas
Hospital,
which is where I was working and the
Orient Patients in the Douglas Hospital
and this was back in the eighties and
those people were like,
she was like super woman compared to the
inpatients at the Douglas Hospital.
Those people looked like they were from
a Hieronymus Bosch painting because they
had deinstitutionalized everyone that
could possibly be deinstitutionalized.
And so the only people that were left
were people who couldn't be dns to
institutionalized.
And so those would have been people who
are in the sight words for like 30
years.
And all of the hospitals were connected
by tunnels underground in the patients
used to hang out down there by the coke
machine and so forth.
And one day I took my brother down
there.
He was visiting and like,
it was just like he just turned white
because it was just really,
I don't know if,
you know,
Hieronymus Bosch,
he's very,
an interesting painter to say the least,
but that's what it was like.
And so,
so here was her idea.
She,
she'd come to the behavior therapy unit
because she had been,
she'd been in the inpatient ward for
awhile and she met some of these like
ruined people and she tried to get the
hospital.
She thought,
well I'm walking my dog,
you know,
what,
maybe I could take one of these patients
out for a walk,
you know,
and she'd been talking to the hospital
administrators trying to get her,
allow her to go take out one of these
patients and go for a walk with her dog.
And basically she had come to the
behavior therapy unit because that's
what she wanted to do.
It's like,
man,
that person,
she just blew me away.
I like,
it's like I just couldn't believe it.
Like she had nothing going for her,
like nothing.
And yet she wanted to,
you know,
help some people that were worse off.
And like there just weren't that many
people that were worse off than her mind
boggling mind boggling and I never
forgot it.
And it really,
it really blew me away.
So you know,
there are opportunities for,
for elevating your sites within your
realm of capability,
wherever you happen to be.
And,
and that's interesting.
It's,
it's strange that that's the case.
She brings those who love,
that's what that should say,
the sweet fulfillment of their secret
longing like a bolt out of the blue fate
characterized here as feminine.
And that's what happens in the movie.
The movie's got a Christian underbelly,
like it's quite pronounced,
but it's really a pagan movie in many
ways.
So for example,
there's no blue fairy in,
and the reason I'm speaking of
Christianity,
of course,
is because this movie was created in a
culture where Christianity was still
reasonably intact.
And of course it was fully informed by
that.
But the underlying mythos is not
precisely Christian,
even though it's informed by Christian
imagery.
There is this old idea,
I think it's a gnostic idea that the
wisdom of God is feminine,
something like that.
And Anima,
which means soul is feminine and so
there's,
there's an idea like that lurking here.
And anyways,
that's fate and that's the blue fairy in
this particular movie,
you know,
she comes down from the star which kind
of makes her an Avatar of God.
That's,
that's the idea.
And she's the transformative agent.
She's really mother nature,
you know,
in her positive guys.
And that's why she can animate to
animate something means to infuse it
with soul.
That's what it means.
And she animates Pinocchio,
right?
She's the,
the forest that frees him from his
strings.
And so that's her fate,
like a bolt out of the blue.
The blue faith steps in and sees you
through.
Well,
what that means,
it means something like mean something
like this is that,
you know,
if you orient yourself properly in the
world and we'll say that you do that by
trying to attain the ultimate goal,
whatever that happens to be,
then it's as if the world is on your
side and,
and,
and things go well for you.
And I also believe that's true because
certainly one of the things that's more
or less self evident is that generally
speaking,
if you tell the truth,
things go a lot better for you.
And the reason for that is,
well,
you want to be,
you want to reality opposed
to you or do you want to have reality
backing you up?
It's like it's a pretty straightforward
question.
If you're truthful to the degree that
you can be truthful,
then reality is on your side.
That's a good thing because there's a
lot of it.
There isn't a bunch of you.
Whereas if you take a deceitful approach
to things,
then while then you're.
You're challenging reality.
It's like,
good,
good luck with that man.
It's like you're holding a plastic ruler
in front of your face and bending it and
at some point you're going to let go and
it's going to all that force that you've
stored up and it's going to snap back
and nail you and that that happens.
Or like I've just never seen anyone in
my clinical practice ever get away with
anything.
Nothing.
And it's not surprising.
It's like if you're going to mess with
the structure of reality,
like it's gonna mess back and it does
and it might not happen for years and
you might not even notice the connection
being part of what you do in
psychotherapy is to actually make those
connections.
It's like,
why did this horrible thing happened to
me?
Well,
who knows?
It's like let's take it apart while May,
who knows how far back we have to go.
It might even have things to do,
not even with you.
It might have things to do with the
errors in your parents' relationship.
Like you just can't mess with the
structure of reality.
It,
it,
it stays warped until you straighten it
out and it is not good.
So,
so there's an injunction here,
which is that,
you know,
if you've followed this path,
you pick a high goal and you put your
heart in it,
you know,
you commit to it,
believe in it.
Believe means to love,
believe and beloved.
It's the same thing.
It means to act out.
And that's what the belief means.
Like we think belief means to accept a
set of propositions as true or that is
one form of belief,
but that's more like factual knowledge,
right?
Belief is more like you decide that
you're going to act something out,
you make a decision and then you act it
out and that's a reflection of your
belief.
You know,
it's,
you're staking yourself on something.
Do you know?
Well no,
because you can't.
You can't know you're bonded by
ignorance.
You can make your best guess and move
forward and you can do that with
commitment,
but you have to believe in order to do
that.
I guess that's why it's a wish.
Okay,
so fine.
Well then we have jimminy cricket that
south southern US Slang for Jesus Christ
by the way.
And the initial overlap isn't a fluke.
I mean,
I'm sure the animators thought that was
funny and of course it is funny and you
know,
in the lion king,
you know that that at boone who is the
Shaman basically?
Well,
to begin with,
he was kind of just a comic relief
character,
like a fool,
you know.
But one of the things you mentioned
about the fool,
the fool tends to turn into the savior.
It's an,
it's an archetypal reality.
Bugs bunny is sort of like that,
you know,
he's a trickster.
And as the,
as the movie developed,
the character of the fool,
baboons took on the full fledged,
you know,
Shaman,
priest element and,
and you know,
okay,
well Jimminy cricket,
he's this little cricket and,
and he turns out to be the conscience,
which is pretty damn weird.
It's like a bug is your conscience and a
bug is JC.
And it's like that's a very strange
juxtaposition of ideas,
conscience,
insect,
savior.
It's like,
what,
what's up with that?
And so,
well,
what bugs you?
That's part of it.
While your conscious conscience
certainly bugs you and you should pay
attention to.
It's just little niggling annoying thing
that you can't quite,
you can override it,
right?
Obviously,
but it's this swell.
And he says,
when he talks to Pinocchio later,
he says it's that still small voice,
you know,
and I've asked people before,
like in my personality class,
like,
because conscience is a weird thing.
And,
and like if I said to you,
if you're about to do something that you
know you shouldn't do,
do you have a voice in your head that
tells you that you shouldn't do it?
So how many people have had that
experience?
Okay,
okay,
good.
Now,
so other people have a feeling instead
of a voice.
And so is there anybody here who's
willing to admit it?
Who has neither the feeling nor the
voice.
Okay.
So,
and you know,
it's a very understudied phenomena in
psychology.
This conscience.
I mean people can be conscientious and
maybe those are people who listen to
their conscience more.
I don't know,
but nobody's ever investigated it.
And the fact that you do have this
little voice,
whatever it is inside your head,
it's like,
what the hell's up with that?
You know?
And it doesn't tell you what you want to
hear least as far as I can tell.
Now you could say,
well that's the internal representation
of society operating within you.
That'd be a Freudian view.
That's the Super Ego.
And certainly there's something to that,
but I don't think it's necessary to
presume that that's all there is to it.
And even if it is,
you still wouldn't have the voice.
It's if you didn't have the biological
potential to have that voice embedded
itself in you.
So even if it is socio culturally
constructed,
which it is in part,
it's like language,
it's like your language associated
culturally constructed.
But the reason you can speak is because
human beings can speak and if you have a
conscience,
it's because human beings have a
conscience and the contents of that
conscience might differ.
But the fact that it exists,
what seems to me to be a universal.
Okay,
so,
well that's the conscience.
And that's Jimminy cricket.
And then crick the cricket opens this
book and then you look at the book and
you think,
well what kind of book is that?
Well,
it's got a spotlight on it.
So it's being highlighted.
This is an important book.
And what kind of book is it?
Well,
it's leather bound.
It has a lock on it,
you know,
it's not something cheap book.
It's kind of like a,
you might think about,
it looks like something from an old
library or maybe it looks biblical,
whatever.
It's a major league book and this bug is
the introduction to the book.
So it does that mean your conscience is
the introduction to the book?
Well maybe that is what it means.
It's certainly what's being played out
in the movie while then the cricket
opens the book and so then what do you
see?
Well,
what does that look like?
What does it look like?
What does it remind you of?
Okay,
so that's the van Gogh painting.
It's a nativity scene.
It's the,
it's the Christmas star and you know
that because what's going to happen?
Well,
the hero is going to be born.
That's what happens.
And so a star signifies that.
Why does this star signify the birth of
an infant,
let's say?
Well,
because there's something miraculous
about the birth of an infant and,
and why would the infant be a savior,
which is the Christian notion say,
well,
because that's what the infant is
potentially every infant.
And so that's how you should act about
them.
And you know,
one of the things that really is
interesting about having little kids,
and I loved having little kids,
is that you have this opportunity to
have this pristine relationship with
someone like,
like a relationship you've never had
with anyone because the kid really is
just there to love you.
You like,
if you don't screw it up,
you've got that.
And then you can keep that going.
You know,
and you can try to keep that
relationship like pristine.
And that's so fun.
It's so fun to try to do that.
It's,
it's really,
it's amazing.
It's an amazing thing and you know,
kids get a bad rap in our society,
but it's an amazing thing to have little
kids and they are remarkable and they
give you back far more than they require
from you.
And partly because they treat you like
you're,
you're valuable beyond belief.
That's what the kid thinks about you.
It's like,
that's pretty good.
So yeah,
it's like something divine is going to
happen and so,
okay,
fine,
you know,
fair enough.
Well,
there's The star signifying that and,
and that's associated in some way with
this star that you're supposed to wish
upon.
Well,
that's Kinda odd.
Like there's this,
there's this relationship that's
implicit,
that star that signifies the birth of
the hero is the same star that you wish
upon.
Well,
perhaps the star that you're wishing
upon is the wish that the hero will be
born in your soul.
It's something like that.
You're aiming at an ideal.
It's the ideal you,
whatever that would be.
Well,
you can certainly figure out what it
isn't.
That's where you start as far as I can
tell,
you know,
what you shouldn't be doing and you
could at least stop doing those things
and then see what happens.
You know,
and if you ask yourself,
it's a meditative exercise,
you know,
and you do this with the autobiography
to some degree.
It's like,
okay,
sit down for minutes and have a little
dialogue
with yourself.
Like you actually wanted to know the
answer,
you know?
So yeah,
ask,
well,
I'm probably doing something stupid that
if I quit doing my life would be better.
That I could quit doing that I would
quit doing and maybe it's not a very big
thing because you're not very
disciplined,
but maybe there's something to ask
yourself that question,
man,
you'll have an answer no time flat.
Like,
well,
I should start doing this.
It's like,
yeah,
I know I didn't,
you know,
I won't,
but.
Or maybe I would,
but if I did,
I know my life would be better.
It's like you can figure that out
immediately and if you do that 100
times,
well you'll be in way better shape.
So if you don't know what to do,
that's good.
You could at least figure out what you
shouldn't do.
That's just moronically pathetic and you
can be sure you're doing like a dozen of
those things.
At least you know,
procrastinating or you know,
you know everyone.
That's what the conscience tells you and
if you ask,
they'll just tell you why you're stupid
and insufficient.
And so who wants to hear that?
But
what?
Maybe you could do something about it.
Okay.
So the cricut comes into the village
there and he sees this,
this little house and there's a little
fire in it and so it's Kinda got a
welcoming place.
It's a light in the darkness,
this house,
just like the star.
And so he hops towards it and then he
ends up inside it and you know,
there's a nice fire and you get to see
the inside and the insights.
It's cozy,
it's welcoming.
And then when you look around you see
that everything's kind of in its place.
It's not hyper organized or anything
like that.
It's friendly and welcoming and it's,
there's a lot of wood and there's a nice
fire and then there's toys everywhere
and they're well constructed.
So you know that whoever lives there
likes children.
And so if someone likes children,
well if someone doesn't like children,
it's like you should run away from them
very rapidly.
But if they liked children,
well then that's a good sign that you
know Jesus there,
at least human.
It's a start,
you know?
And then these things are all high
quality.
They're made very well.
And then there's,
and he's looking around to see all of
this and there's,
there's toys and there's clocks and
they're all handmade and so he sort of
infers that maybe there's a woodcarver,
who,
who lives there and a woodcarver.
Someone who,
who can build things.
And if you build things that work and
that are beautiful,
that's,
that's a kind of truth,
right?
It's like it's built right into the
object.
That's what quality is.
Quality is the,
the building into an object of truth.
The thing works.
It does what it's supposed to.
It has integrity.
And so you see that everywhere inherent.
So you're getting a sense of that.
The filmmakers are setting the stage and
so while.
So they set the stage by showing you the
stage and the cricket tells you what he
sees and he's pretty happy to be there
because.
And this is also someone who's concerned
about time,
right?
Because there's a lot of clocks,
there's a lot of clocks.
And so time turns out to be an important
sub element of this story.
And then he sees the puppet marionette.
And so what's a marion out?
Well,
a marionette.
He's sitting on the shelf.
A marionette is something that's
[inaudible] animated because it can
move,
it doesn't really have a soul,
but it sort of acts like it has a soul
it in,
in,
in the sense of anima and soul.
It animated and.
But a Marionette is something that is
being manipulated by something else
behind the scenes,
right?
It doesn't have its own volition.
It's,
it's dependent on the will have
something behind the scenes and so
there's a strong implication that
whatever this thing is is half formed
and that it's being manipulated by
unseen forces behind unseen forces
behind the facade.
Well,
that's a Friday.
An idea that's you.
That's all of you.
You know,
you're polled hither and fro by
unconscious forces and some of those are
biological and some of them are
cultural.
You know,
and you think about people who are swept
up in great ideological movements like
the Communists or the fascist is like
those people are marionettes.
That's exactly what they are.
They all say the same thing.
They all mount the same words.
They all act the same way and some
things behind it.
And the question is what will,
that is the question and that's partly
what this movie tries to figure out.
So you see this Marionette,
he's at half formed,
wouldn't headed puppet and he has a
little bit of potential,
you know,
and the cricket goes up and interacts
with them and sees that he's made out of
pretty good.
Would it makes a little joke about
having a wooden head and you know,
that's kind of obvious what that means.
And you noticed the cricket is dressed
like a tramp.
And,
and when you first saw him he wasn't,
he was dressed like in 19 twenties,
millionaire.
So,
but now,
but here he's a tramp and this is so
interesting.
It's like,
so this bug,
that's a messiah,
that's the introduction to the book,
that's the conscience is also a tramp
with no home.
It's like what does that mean?
And it took me a long time to sort that
out.
And it's like he's been everywhere.
This tramp,
he's been everywhere and,
and he knows he's,
he's traveled the world and anybody who
doesn't have a place,
he doesn't have a home.
He hasn't made a relationship with
anything real yet.
He's.
He's kind of a potential,
and this is one of the things that's
really interesting about this movie
because if you think about the cricket
as a fragment of the of the hero and say
a,
a reflection of the of the savior,
which is his relationship with JCC of
course,
and the person who introduces the book,
then the story gets strange because if
it was merely a representation of the
perfect person,
the archetype of the hero,
then the conscience would know
everything,
right,
and it would just tell the puppet what
to do and that would be the end of it,
but that,
first of all,
that's adult story.
It's like perfect conscience comes
along.
Puppet does everything.
It says Bingo perfection,
but that isn't what happens.
There's this weird idea that this thing
that's got all these attributes needs a
home and has
to enter into a learning relationship
with the thing that it's trying to
transform.
It's so sophisticated because you know,
I could say you should do what your
conscience tells you.
It's like,
well,
maybe not.
Maybe that's not exactly how it works.
Maybe your conscience isn't omniscient
and omnipotent.
Maybe it's not gone right.
It's a guide,
but it's.
It's,
it's,
it's maybe smarter than you sometimes.
Maybe because it's society in your head
and obviously it's smarter than you
sometimes because it tells you not to do
something and you go do it and then you
get into trouble and he's like,
what if I would've just listened?
But you don't.
And that's interesting too.
It's something that you don't have to
listen to,
which is seems to be associated with
freewill.
It's weird.
It's like if your conscience knows what
to do,
why aren't you just a deterministic
puppet of your conscience Christ?
That would work a lot better.
You wouldn't have to torture yourself
and you would make any mistakes.
So why the separation?
Well,
maybe it's because of the conscience is
generic
and so it has to be taught.
It has to learn to.
And so what you do is you have a
dialogue with your conscience.
It's something like that and then you
expose yourself to more and more of the
world and you get wiser in your
conscience.
Gets wiser and you,
you mature together and that's what
happens in this story because the
cricket starts out as a tramp that,
you know,
is smarter than the puppet but not as
smart as he thinks he is.
That's for sure.
And when he first starts to operate as a
conscience,
he's completely useless.
Added.
He babbles off a lot of cliches about
morality and then he's late the first
day for his job and he's just not very
good at it.
And so there's this weird idea that the
conscience,
which is part of what puts you towards
redemption,
is something that you actually have to
interact with over the course of your
life in order for it to develop as you
develop.
And so then I would also say that the
cricket represents,
at least in part what you described as
the self,
which is like the potential fully
developed human being that sort of
exists within you as a possibility,
but it has to be.
It has to be manifest in the actual
conditions of your life.
And so the conscience has to learn how
to position itself here and now.
And it's got generic advice and that's
not good enough.
And so that's why the cricket is looking
for a home.
And so he needs a home even though he's
all these other things we already said
he was,
he has to find a specific home before he
can become who he could be.
Well,
so then Japan,
oh,
shows up and he's a kindly old guy,
which is pretty much exactly what you'd
expect.
And you know,
he,
he's a careful craftsman and he likes
kittens and you know,
that's always a good thing.
And he has some fish and I know he's.
And He's good at making things and he's
got a sense of humor and he's kind of
playful.
And so he's,
he's a,
he's a good father.
Fundamentally.
He's the wise king.
He's the positive archetype of the
masculine.
That's what he is.
And so he's culture and it's positive
manifestation.
And he gives rise to this creation,
which is his puppet,
which is what culture does because
you're a puppet of your culture,
you're a Marionette of your culture.
And so maybe you could be more than
that.
And that's the other thing that's
strange about this movie,
and it's strange about the mythological
way of looking at the world because
scientifically deterministically,
there's nature and there's culture and
you are the deterministic product of the
interaction between nature and culture.
There's nothing else to you than that.
That's that.
But the mythological world doesn't say
that.
It says something different.
It says that there's nature and culture
and then there's you
and the you that's in there has choices
and the destiny and that you actually
affect the interplay of nature and
culture in determining your own
character.
And it insists upon that.
The oldest stories we have,
there's always the hero and the
archetypal mother and the archetype of
father.
There's always those three things.
There's never just two.
So from a narrative perspective,
there's always the implication that
there is something autonomous about the,
the hero of the story and you know,
you can't account for that.
We don't have a good way of accounting
for that.
From a scientific perspective.
I was having a discussion with Sam
Harris the other day,
which was very.
What would you say?
He said we got wrapped around an axle,
which is pretty much has.
Sam Harris is one of the four famous,
you know,
atheists along with Christopher Hitchens
and Richard Dawkins and Dan Dennett.
Yeah.
And so we were having a discussion and
um,
he's a determinist just right down to
the bottom.
It's like you're determined,
you're determined,
there's no freewill.
You're a deterministic machine.
And you know,
if you're a coherent scientist and
you're a Newtonian,
roughly speaking,
you don't really have much choice other
than to think that way,
but that isn't how it seems to people
and we don't treat each other that way.
And our entire legal system is
predicated on the idea that you do in
fact have freewill.
So.
Well,
can we account for it?
no.
And do we have a scientific model for
it?
No,
but then I would also say we do not have
a scientific model for consciousness.
We don't know a damn thing about
consciousness,
which is why Dan Dennett book,
which was called consciousness
explained,
was referred to.
It's by it's critics as consciousness
explained a way,
which is exactly right as far as I'm
concerned because he took a mechanistic
approach and I just don't think you get
to do that because there's something
really weird about consciousness.
I mean the phenomenologists Heidegger,
who tried to radically transformed
Western philosophy right from the bottom
up.
He basically said,
well,
you know,
you can treat the world as if
consciousness is primary and that human
experience is reality.
That's reality and that he doesn't exist
independently of consciousness in any
explicable way.
It's like,
well,
what's out there?
If there's nothing to experience
it,
well,
everything at once.
It's something like that.
It's not really comprehensible as
without a subject that subject defines
it.
It makes it real.
Now you don't have to believe that,
but,
but at least I'm telling you that there
are thoroughly coherent philosophical
positions that make that case very
strongly and that that allow
consciousness to exist as a phenomena
and to take it seriously and you
certainly act like you take it
seriously.
You Act like there's a you and that you
make choices and you certainly treat
other people that way.
Deterministic or not,
you're still gonna get angry when
they're being rude to you and you're
going to act as if they had some choice
in the matter.
Now,
maybe that's an illusion possibly,
but maybe it's not.
And I would say the oldest stories that
we have always include that as not only
as a fundamental element,
but even as the fundamental element so.
Well,
so you can think about that however you
want.
But anyways,
so Japan comes along and he's going to
finish off the puppet.
And so what does he do to finish off the
puppet?
He gives it a.
It gives it a voice.
It gives it a mouth.
Well,
that's really,
really interesting.
So in Genesis,
in Genesis,
this is a,
this is a very,
very,
very complex idea and it took people
thousands of years to figure this idea
out and it's something like this is so
at the beginning of everything,
there was chaos and that was like
potential.
It was something like potential,
the potential for being and God who is
God.
The father in the genesis account uses a
faculty that he has,
which is the word to call being from
chaos and that's the creation of Ba,
right?
It's the.
It's the manifestation of order from
chaos and it's the word,
the logos that it's.
It's the logos.
That's the tool that God uses to do that
and that logos in Christianity is
associated with Christ,
which is a very weird thing,
but the reason for that is that there's
an idea that the divine element of the
individual is the thing that uses
language,
communicative language to call the world
into being,
and that is what we do as far as we can
tell.
It's like you make a decision,
you think it through and talk it over
with your friends.
You plot a course and the world
manifests itself in relationship to your
choice and it's for that reason and it
is for that reason that in genesis and
in many other accounts that that logo's
capacity is identified with human
beings.
It's like you have a small bit of that
in you.
Whatever that means,
and you participate in the process of
continually generating order out of
chaos and and sometimes the reverse,
you mediate between them and so and that
is that in our,
in,
in Western culture and certainly the
case at other cultures as well,
that that's why you have rights.
Fundamentally.
That's why the law has to respect you is
because you've got this spark of
divinity in you that's transcendent that
nobody gets to transgress against and
you say,
well,
do you believe that?
It's like,
well,
you act like you believe it.
You treat other people like you believe
it or they're not very happy with you.
So it depends on what you mean by
believe you act it out.
Well.
Do you accept it as a proposition?
Oh,
I don't care if you accept that as a
proposition frankly,
because I think the best indicator of
what you believe is how you act.
Not what you say because what do you
know about what you know?
Hardly anything and so actions speak
louder than words and if you want to be
treated properly by someone,
what that means is that you want to
treat them,
you want them to treat you as a valuable
autonomous entity.
That's what you want.
And so maybe you're not that.
Maybe you're a deterministic puppet and
what this strange movie suggests is that
you are kind of a deterministic puppet,
but you don't have to be all right,
well you the mouth goes on and then
Japan was happy about that and then they
have a little dance,
you know,
they,
they turned the music on and all these
little music boxes and they all play
together and it's like harmony of some
sort has been established because that's
what the music represents and the layers
of reality that are communicating with
one another because that's what the
music represents.
And then they have a little dance and
the idea is that,
well,
it's a good thing to let this puppet
habits own voice.
Well,
that's an interesting idea because what
the hell does it?
No,
it's a wooden headed marionette.
Why the hell would you want something
like that to talk?
Well,
it's the same question you have in
relationship to your children.
It's like what do they know there two or
three,
you know,
they don't know anything.
Well,
so should you just like tyrannized them
and make them do everything you want?
Are you going to let them have a bit of
a voice?
And the question is,
it depends on whether do we want them to
be a puppet or not.
And if you don't want them to be a
puppet,
if you want them to grow up atonomous
then you let them have a voice and you
facilitate the development of that voice
and so and,
and,
and that's.
And that's what you do if you don't want
a marionette.
So in Japan who doesn't want a
Marionette?
So he gives the puppet a voice even
though he knows it's just a puppet and
that it's,
it doesn't know anything.
And then this is fantastic.
So the cricket sitting up there watching
that,
he's pretty happy with it.
That's the first little CDC there and
he's sitting by this other thing that is
just not happy at all and that's the
terrible father.
And you see it's a character that
repeats throughout the entire movie.
You see manifestations of the tyrannical
father continually through the movie in
different characters like he's played
out by different roles.
And so first of all,
the cricket is so thrilled about this.
And then he looks at the frowning king
there who's,
who is not happy that the puppet has
been given a voice.
He's a tyrant.
He's the representation of a tyrant and
a tyrant does not want you to have a
voice.
And so the cricket looks at him and
says,
well,
you can't please everybody all the time.
And it's just this tiny little fragment
of a joke,
you know.
But it's,
there's this old idea.
I think it comes from checkoff and,
and the idea is that if you set a
playoff and,
and there's a gun,
a rifle or a pistol on a table in the
first act,
it better have been used by the third
act or it shouldn't have been there at
all.
And the idea is you don't put anything
in your play that it's random,
you never do that.
It's like,
because this isn't life,
that,
that this isn't life.
This is a work of art and everything is
connected and it's caught,
you know,
it's,
it's there by intent.
And so this isn't accidental that this
little king character doesn't like
what's going on or that he shows up.
So anyways,
all,
all the clocks go off and the music
boxes go and they have a little dance
and everybody's happy about it.
And,
and then Japan notices what time it is.
And so there's a tremendous emphasis on
time in this part of the movie because
there are all these clocks are going off
and they're all telling him what time it
is,
like 30 clocks go off.
And then he takes us,
watch out and notices what time it is.
It's like the idea that there's
something about time going on is like
whacked at you,
you know,
dozens of times so that you get it.
And it's a little joke that he pulls out
his watch and he figures out it's time
for bed.
While.
So now we're making a transition between
the conscious world and the unconscious
world.
Okay.
So,
so there's an intimation in the movie
that everything that happens now is in
the unconscious world.
And the way you know that is that it's,
it's strange because the movie moves in
and out of this underworld.
But at the very end when Pinocchio
transformed into a real boy,
the last thing Japan does is I think
it's Japan always hit one of the
pendulums and start all the clocks
again.
So it's as if what happens from here
onwards is part of a dream.
Now it's,
it's murky because Pinocchio goes to
school and you know,
there's the next day and all of that.
But.
And so those are sort of realistic
elements.
But then there's also the whole going
down into the ocean to find the whale
thing,
which seems completely dreamlike and,
but there's an intimation that we're in
a different kind of world.
And,
and so we go to,
they all go to sleep,
including the cricket.
And so then Japan notices the star and
because he's a good guy,
he makes a wish on the start.
We've already explained why you might
wish on a star and what that might mean,
and he makes a very interesting wish.
Um,
it's,
it's not a self serving wish.
In fact,
it's quite the contrary.
He doesn't wish that Pinocchio is an
obedient son.
He doesn't wish that he's produced
someone who will work for him.
He doesn't wish any of that.
He wishes what a good father would wish,
which is that the creation that he's
brought forth would develop
its capacity for autonomy.
He wants them to become real.
He wants him to become an actual living
creature and not a wooden headed
marionette.
And so you'd say,
well,
that is what your father should wish for
you.
You know,
and I have clients frequently whose
fathers weren't like that at all.
They were tyrannical or they were
neglectful or,
or they punished this.
Then the person,
every time they did something good,
that's a real fun game.
They competed with them and undermining
them at every opportunity.
They didn't want to produce someone
strong and autonomous.
They wanted to give birth to a slave and
then diminish it as much as possible.
And so that's bad,
it's not good and not so Japan was not
like that.
So he says,
well,
I'm going to wish for something
completely unreasonable,
which is that part of that ideal idea,
right?
And they're unreasonable thing is that
this puppet could become real,
could actually take on its autonomy and,
and move forward.
And so that's what he wishes.
And then they go to sleep
and then the cricket starts to become
driven mad by the noises of the clock.
And so it's like he's going into this
sort of state of hyper alertness and the
clocks are clanging out.
Him in Japan was snoring and,
and that he can even hear the little
grains of sand falling out of the,
out of the hourglass.
He's becoming hyper alert,
hyper alert,
and then he yells,
stop.
And all the clock stop.
Which is a pretty good trick for a
cricket.
You know,
it's like he's the master of time.
But also we're in a place now where time
has come to a stop or outside of time.
And one of the things that Freud pointed
about,
dreams is that dreams are kind of
outside of time.
Now,
here's what that means is,
is first of all,
they draw and eternal themes.
That's part of it.
But you know,
he must have had this experience.
And Freud noted this carefully in the
interpretation of dreams where you know
you're sleeping and the alarm goes off
and the alarm noise is incorporated into
your dream.
And it's like the dream has been going
on for an hour in subjective time and
you wake up and you realize that it's
the alarm clock.
It's like.
And there's no reason why your dream
time should be the same as real time
because it's all going on in your
imagination.
But it's amazing in some sense how much
can happen in such a short period of
time in your imagination.
And so it's outside of time.
The world of fantasy is in some sense
out of outside of time.
And so the cricket tells time to stop
and it does.
And then the star enlarges and it turns
into this blue fairy who's got a
celestial Gao covered with stars.
And who's got wings,
so she's kind of some ethereal being and
like you don't have a problem with that
in the movie.
It's like,
yeah,
sure.
I mean,
you know,
it's a,
it came from a star.
That makes perfect sense,
which of course it does.
It makes no sense whatsoever.
Right.
It makes no sense,
but you're willing to go along with it
because on the one hand it makes sense.
No sense.
And on the other hand it makes perfect
sense.
It's like the fairy godmother idea.
It's like,
yeah,
fairy Godmother,
no problem.
We got back and it's in the idea there
is that,
well nature comes to your aid.
It's something like that.
It's,
it's the benevolent force of nature is
on your side now,
not obviously only on your side because
it opposes you as well,
but then there's your own mother as well
who's also nature who's on your site.
And so there's an idea here and the idea
is that if the father gets the wish
right,
the aim right for the child,
then nature will cooperate.
Right?
And that's true,
I believe that's true,
is that if you set up your relationship,
your cultural relationship with your
child properly,
then they're far more likely to
flourish.
And so you get the magic of nature on
your side by establishing the proper
aim.
And so that's what happens.
Japan.
Oh says,
well,
this is what I.
This is what I'm aiming at and because
he's aiming at at it and because it's
within the realm of possibility,
nature comes to his service and that is
how it works.
And that's exactly how it works.
Because when you aim at something,
then you muster your biological forces
towards that goal and if the goal is
feasible and attainable,
then you will cooperate with yourself.
And so that's quite cool.
Carl Rogers would call that.
What's the word for that?
I think he called a genuineness,
which is kind of weak,
but I think.
I think that's still what he called it
and he started meant that,
well,
that's sort of what happens when your,
when your goals and your physiological
and biological being are aligned well
and you're and you can communicate both.
You're not full of internal
contradictions,
and so your conscious aims and your
biological possibilities are manifesting
themselves in the same direction and so
while that would be good,
so anyways,
the fairy shows up and she's quite
sexually attractive.
She's quite provocative and she,
she charmed the cricket and who gets all
blushes and like is all,
you know,
embarrassed and overwhelmed by this
figure of celestial beauty and decides
to cooperate.
The conscience decides to cooperate and
get some responsibility.
And so the ferry allows the puppet to
move without strings.
So that's kind of interesting.
So it's the intervention of nature.
Culture focuses the aim,
then it's the intervention of nature
that produces the autonomy and that
seems to be right.
I mean,
even though it's not that
understandable,
it seems to be right.
And then so she takes the strings off
Pinocchio and you might say,
well,
that's partly because your child is not
certainly
not just a creature of culture.
By no means your child has a
temperament.
You'll see that right away and that
temperament will unfold and hopefully
it'll unfold in a cultural context
that's amenable to it.
And that the combination of those two
things will produce something new,
you can talk,
he could walk.
And so the good fairy basically tells
him that he's got a bit of autonomy and
now it's up to him to like clue in Tibet
and act properly and learn the
difference between good and evil and to
speak truthfully and all that.
It's a bit a propaganda stick.
That part of the movie I would say,
but it doesn't really matter.
It's kind of inculcation of conventional
morality and there's a fair bit to it,
especially that he's supposed to tell
the truth.
And uh,
you know,
he says he will and the crickets
listing.
And then the puppet asks,
well,
what does consciousness mean?
Because the ferry says,
always let your conscience be your
guide.
And he says,
what is conscience mean?
And then the bug who's like all puffed
up because he wants to impress the ferry
pops down and gets on his little
matchbox and gives this like horrible
little lecture about how to behave
properly.
That's just like ideological chatter.
You could hardly even stand listening to
it.
And it's supposed to be like that.
It's generic moral advice that anyone
could give that's kind of dull and,
and also puffed up and grandiose and
he's just not very good at it.
So,
and that's why he's on his little
matchbox there with his chest puffed
out.
And so he says that's just the travel
with the world today.
And uh,
and I think that's his opening line,
you know,
he's diagnosing the whole world and you
know,
the ferry,
she thinks he's kind of funny because he
is and you know,
it's sort of,
there's a real interesting thing here
going on because he's male and he's,
he's all puffed up with,
with his knowledge,
which is completely shallow.
And then he's put in contact with this
celestial feminine ideal and he just
turns into a complete moron.
And that's exactly what happens to men.
It happens to them all the time.
So anyways,
she decides to give him a chance and
turns them into this conscience and all
of a sudden he's this like 19 twenties
millionaire.
So He's been,
he's been unknowable.
But then she tells him that,
you know,
he has to journey along with Pinocchio
in order for things to go properly and
he promises that he'll be a good
conscience and do it and he already
thinks that he can do it and that's why
he's on the matchbox podium,
you know,
espousing his morality.
But the reality turns out to be much
more complex
so
the bog has a little talk with the
cricket.
The bug has a little talk with the
puppet and the Bug tries to tell
Pinocchio explicitly what it means to be
good and he gets completely tangled up
in the explanation because what the hell
does he know?
And the puppet doesn't understand
anything that he says anyways.
And so there's a message there and the
message is the kind of knowledge that
the conscience is that the conscience
and the puppet are supposed to cocreate
is not something that you can articulate
easily as a table of rules.
It's not like that because life is too
complicated to just have fought five
rules that you live by and that will
solve every problem partly because the
rules will conflict.
That's a huge part of the problem,
right?
One moral guideline contradicts another
into situations like you don't know what
to do.
So anyways,
they decide that they're.
They decided that they're just going to.
He says,
Pinocchio says,
well,
I'll be a good boy,
and the cricket says,
well that's the spirit,
and then,
well then Japan gets wind of it and they
have a little like horror episode and
and then he finds out that the public
can is autonomous and they have a little
party which tells you exactly what Japan
goes up to is the autonomy emerges and
he's happy about it.
So it's stamping home the notion that
you pedo is in fact a good guy and that
that is in fact what he wants.
So it's like the encouragement of your
father is a precondition for the
emergence of your individuality and,
and it also allows the feminine to play
a role both as nature and perhaps as
mother.
And so and the combination of those two
things produces the autonomous
individual.
It's like,
well that seems perfectly reasonable.
So off they go to sleep,
next day they wake up and it's a new day
and,
and a Pinocchio is off to school.
And that's a good thing too because
Japan,
oh,
isn't,
and he's really excited about it and so
what that means is that he's been
parented properly and,
and he's going to go out into the world
of his peers,
which is where he belongs.
And Japan isn't too worried about it.
In fact,
he,
he's pushed them out the door,
you know,
it's like go,
you can do it,
this is the next thing.
The kid isn't cowering in the corner and
overcome by terror with the parents
freaking out about all the things that
are going to go wrong.
It's,
there's some faith in his,
his ability.
So he sees all the kids wandering by
and,
and Japan Eto dresses them up and sends
them off to school and so and so.
That's good.
So that's a happy family story.
It's like mom and dad got together.
They decided that there,
the kid was going to be competent and
autonomous and ready to face the world.
And so our egos.
And so he's like five years old at this
point or something like that and that's
where we get,
that's where we're at in the story and I
think that's a good place to stop
because the next thing that happens is
normally essentially it's like Pinocchio
goes off to be a good boy,
but it turns out that's a hell of a lot
more complicated than he might think
because there are actually complications
in the world,
but also malevolence right?
The desire for things not to go right.
There are people who are not oriented
towards the ideal in any way at all.
And Pinocchio's young and naive.
And so he has no defense whatsoever
against this malevolence.
And that's,
you know,
that's not an expect,
not unexpected.
And it also turns out that the
conscience,
the cricket,
who is still not very clued in over
sleeps.
And so he's just not there at a critical
moment.
But I think we'll pick that up.
We'll pick that up next week because
this is a good point in the plot to
stop.
The child has entered the broader world
and has to cope with it.
And so he's prepared because he had a
wonderful father and he had a magical
mother and so he's as prepared as you
can be.
He's not even completely a marionette
anymore,
but,
but now it's up to him.
That's the thing.
Now it's up to him and his parents have
done basically what they could.
And that's really about right.
You know,
um,
it's,
it's wise,
I would say psychologically.
So.
Alright,
that's,
that.